[musique]
Amiral, mesdames et messieurs, nous
sommes heureux d'accueillir ce soir les
éconoclastes qui ouvrent le cycle annuel
de nos conférences.
Ils vont nous livrer leur compréhension
du monde sous l'angle économique, l'une
des facettes de la géopolitique.
de SN tank pluridisciplinaire et composé
de chefs d'entreprise qui ne
s'interdisent d'aborder aucun sujet
vont nous livrer en toute indépendance
sans tabou
des clés pour apporter des éclairages
sur la situation économique
et nous permettre de lectures nouvelles
et nous donner l'opportunité de penser
autrement.
Vous aurez d'abord un discours à deux
voix avec Olivier de la Marche. Olivier
de la Marche, vous avez toujours
travaillé dans le milieu de la finance.
Vous vous définissez vous-même comme un
sérial entrepreneur.
Vous êtes à la tête aujourd'hui de trois
entreprises.
Ce qui nous laisse à penser que vous
maîtrisez votre sujet.
Vous ne mâchez pas vos mots
et dites toujours ce que vous pensez,
ce qui vous a valu de belles chroniques
pendant 8 années sur BFM Business.
Ce discours à deux voix sera établi avec
Pierre Sabattier. Pierre Sabattier,
ingénieur agronome de formation. Vous
êtes aujourd'hui convaincu que le doute
et l'humilité sont les deux meilleurs
outils pour comprendre le monde. En plus
de présider aujourd'hui le cabinet
indépendant de recherche économique et
financière,
Primeview, vous enseignez notamment au
Conservatoire National des arts et
métiers et à Agrotec Paris. Vous mettez
ainsi vos qualités pédagogiques au
service des éconoclastes pour nous
aider. à mieux comprendre le monde et à
prendre des décisions éclairées. Cette
conférence sera ensuite animée par Alain
Juillet. Alain Juillet, vous êtes un des
trois vous êtes des trois intervenants
du jour, celui qui connaissait le mieux
le monde militaire au sein duquel vous
intervenez.
Vous avez en effet servi pendant 5 ans
comme officier au sein du service action
de ce qui est devenu la DGSE.
Vous avez ensuite mené une carrière
riche alternant poste de direction
d'entreprise et de haut fonctionnaires,
exerçant notamment les fonctions de
conseiller pour l'intelligence
économique en France auprès du premier
ministre. Messieurs, je vous cède
respectueusement la parole.
mieux. Non non, c'est c'est mieux.
Ça ira mieux.
Bon, d'abord merci de nous avoir
réinvité.
En général, on nous invite qu'une fois,
c'est souvent le cas. Donc euh merci euh
d'avoir pris ce risque. Euh on était là
il y a 10 mois à peine
déjà
déjà euh on vous avait dépint une
situation qui était
rose
presque euh teinté de rouge et et
malheureusement
je ne suis pas sûr que la situation est
évoluée favorablement.
Alors, [raclement de gorge] on va pas
reprendre ce qu'on vous avait dit il y a
10 mois.
On va juste voir qu'il y a eu quelques
évolutions.
Nous avons
[raclement de gorge] eu une expérience
avec
un garçon qui a été élu en France et qui
a une pensée complexe paraît-il, qu'il
est souvent difficile à suivre.
[grognement]
Et euh donc on verra ce que ça a donné
quelques mois plus tard. Et puis on a eu
un nouvel arrivant sur la scène
euh qui est le président des États-Unis
euh qui
gère beaucoup de choses par Twitter.
C'est un une mode un mode de présidence
nouveau euh qui fait quelquefois
réagir beaucoup et on va voir que il a
une un mode de fonctionnement euh qui
est qui est pas inintéressant mais qui
n'aboutit pas forcément à ce que pensent
les gens, c'est-à-dire à une reprise
formidable aux États-Unis. on va vous
démontrer que [raclement de gorge] cette
reprise est un peu en trompleuil euh et
que il a amené euh de nouveaux risques
euh notamment
des risques économiques mais aussi des
risques financiers et on
[raclement de gorge] va vous montrer que
le l'avenir pourrait ne pas être aussi
rose que ce qu'on vous disait il y a 10
mois. Voilà. Donc on va commencer par
notre petit tour du monde économique par
les États-Unis. Les États-Unis, il y a
deux il y a deux points. Euh ce que ce
qu'a lancé monsieur Trump au niveau du
commerce international.
Donc ça c'est la partie économique et ce
qu'a déclenché aussi monsieur Trump au
niveau financier.
Vous savez qu'au niveau financier depuis
la crise de 2008 en gros on a on a fait
tourner la planche à billet
dans des proportions qu'on avait jamais
connu.
toutes les banques centrales l'ont fait
et donc ça a amené un un un surplu de
liquidité
comme on en avait jamais connu.
Peut-être avant de rentrer dans le
détail, on peut peut-être faire un
parallèle quand même pour resituer le
programme de Donald Trump parce que
beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui, il faut
faire attention dans lorsqu'on fait de
la prospectime à toujours regarder le
monde, en tout cas nos interlocuteurs,
pas forcément avec nos propres yeux en
imaginant en fait qu'il raisonnent de la
même manière que nous. Et je pense c'est
important lorsqu'on aborde les
États-Unis quand même de revenir au tout
départ sur l'essentiel ou l'essence du
programme de du Donald Trump et les
raisons pour lesquelles il a été élu. Il
a été élu parce que America First, c'est
l'essentiel en fait de son slogan. Et
souvent on vous présente Donald Trump
comme quelqu'un qui est impulsif qui
réagit à coup de tweet. Certes. Alors
soyez sûr que tout ça est tout à fait
programmé et s'inscrit dans une
dynamique assez lisible lorsqu'on prend
un petit peu de hauteur et on déborde en
fait de la simple réaction qu'on peut
lire sur Twitter. America First a quand
même été un tour de force au départ
celui de doper artificiellement la
croissance. Pourquoi ? Parce que
lorsqu'on arrive à la tête des
États-Unis avec un socle électoral
finalement assez fragile, la première
chose qu'on essaie de faire, c'est le
consolider. Et finalement, lorsqu'on
parle, vous savez qu'il y a une grande
réforme fiscale aux États-Unis qui éta
adoptée l'année dernière et si
aujourd'hui la croissance américaine
atteint plus de 4 % 2è trimestre,
quelque chose de lunaire pour nous. On a
ça fait très très longtemps qu'on a pas
atteint ce genre de chose. Pourquoi ?
C'est assez orchestré, hein, c'est
acheté. grâce en fait une baisse des
impôts colossales à la fois pour les
entreprises et les ménages américains.
Faut pas se tromper, il le sait très
bien, les conséquences économique de
cette réforme de cette réforme fiscale
et de la baisse des impôts, c'est
essentiellement le conforter quant à sa
capacité à générer de la croissance aux
États-Unis dans le cadre en fait des
élections qui vont arriver jusque-l. Et
ça marche. Ça marche. Alors attention
parce que comme tu disais,
ça marche aux États-Unis,
ce qui est amusant, c'est que nous on
essaie désespérément aussi en Europe
d'acheter de la croissance puisque de
toute façon le fonctionnement
aujourd'hui est un fonctionnement par la
dette. Mais c'est un fonctionnement par
la dette que ce soit de la dette
publique ou que ce soit de la dette
privée, mais c'est un fonctionnement qui
est euh mondial.
Pourquoi ? Ben tout simplement parce que
vous avez bien compris que de toute
façon la croissance telle qu'elle est
calculée, ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y en
a pas d'autres mais telle qu'elle est
calculée aujourd'hui c'est une
croissance quantitative. On ne parle pas
de qualitatif et donc cette croissance
est basée uniquement et presque
uniquement sur la consommation des
ménages. Or la consommation des ménages,
je vais vous faire on va retourner en
CM2. C'est assez simple, c'est une
question de pure math d'algèbre.
Quand pour consommer plus, il faut que
vous ayez une rémunération
supplémentaire.
Et si vous ne l'avez pas, bah qu'est-ce
que vous faites ? Vous fonctionnez avec
de la dette. C'est simple, quand il y a
pas d'argent tout de suite, qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ? On s'endettete et on verra
plus tard. Alors ça, les États l'ont
bien compris et aujourd'hui, on essaie
désespérément d'acheter de la croissance
à coup de dette.
Le seul problème, c'est que on consomme
tout de suite et qu'on paye la dette
pendant 20 ans et cette dette est de
plus en plus lourde. Donc qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire dans cet environnement
? Et bien, il faut
à à il faut à minima que les banques
centrales soient avec vous et qu'on
continue cette politique de planche à
billet tôt à zéro. Malheureusement,
c'est mortel. On va le on va expliquer
pourquoi. Mais et alors curieusement,
ça donne 4 % aux États-Unis,
ça donne pas 4 % dans le reste du monde.
Allez savoir pourquoi. Peut-être qu'on
est moins malin queux, mais
ce que vous avez dans les 4 % vous ne
l'aurez jamais, même si on dépense la
même chose en France. Curieusement,
l'argent doit se perdre quelque part.
Voilà. Donc
alors mais quand même pour revenir à la
à la chose, ça fonctionne. C'està dire
que premièrement la croissance fait
qu'il assi finalement sa base
électorale. La deuxième il faut vraiment
en fait raisonner à mon sens l'économie
est un est un outil pour conforter sa
position politique. Premier point de la
croissance. Bah les gens, les
entreprises aujourd'hui peuvent plus
investir parce que les baisses d'impôts,
c'est très simple he c'est comme si vous
vous avez à payer en fin d'année vos
impôts, mais d'un coup on vous dit je
paye plus, il y a plus à payer. Donc là
forcément vous vous en bénéficiez, vous
êtes content. Ça c'est le premier point.
Deuxième point, en général c'est
classique. Lorsqu'on est fragile, on va
chercher quoi pour essayer de légitimer
sa position ? des bouqu émissaires.
C'est exactement ce que fait Donald
Trump en fait depuis le début d'année.
Il y a quelque chose qui s'est passé
quand même au premier semestre, quelque
chose d'assez novateur. On avait pas vu
ça depuis 20 ans. C'est quand même une
remise en question profonde. Alors on le
voit à travers les journaux jour le
jour. On a l'impression que ça se fait
progressivement. Mais il faut bien avoir
en tête que ce qui se passe sur
notamment les tarifs doués, c'est
quelque chose d'extraordinaire par
rapport aux 20 dernières années. Le
monde s'est construit depuis 20 ans sur
la base de l'ouverture commerciale. Pour
la première fois, un homme politique va
vers une forme de moindre ouverture
commerciale. Il est trop tôt pour parler
de fermeture commerciale. Alors ça la
question fondamentale c'est à quoi ça
sert ? À quoi ça sert ? Et à qui ça sert
? Ça sert à Donald Trump parce qu'il
peut dire "Je fais ce que j'avais dit à
l'époque, jusque- là, nous sommes les
dindons de la farce." Ils en ont
beaucoup profité. C'est c'est un peu
falacieux comme argument mais nous
sommes les dindons de la farce depuis 20
ans. Avec moi ça suffit. Je sais imposer
des rapports de force et vous allez voir
ce que vous allez voir, je le ferai. Et
concrètement, c'est ce qui se passe
maintenant depuis un certain nombre de
mois puisque vous avez vu qu'au début
juillet, les États-Unis ont taxé donc à
peu près 60 milliards de mémoires en
fait de dollars d'importation chinoise
sur leur territoire et que depuis le
début du mois, le milieu du mois, ils
ont rajouté 200 milliards à ces 60
milliards. Ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui 260 milliards des
importations en provenance de Chine sont
taxées de droits de supplémentaire
aujourd'hui de 10 % au 1er janvier de 25
%. Donc et et la question aujourd'hui
qu'il faut vraiment se poser, ça ça sème
du trouble hein. Ça s'aime du trouble
quand pendant 25 ans, les règles du jeu
ont été celles de commercer ou voilà
sans finalement sans règles puisque
c'est un peu le sujet et que pour la
première fois en fait de l'histoire
depuis 25 ans, vous avez quelqu'un qui
avait dit bien non les règles du jeu
vont évoluer, il va falloir s'y adapter.
Alors la réaction classique par rapport
à ça et par rapport aux observateurs,
c'est de juger que c'est mal hein. Ça
c'est très européen. C'est dire qu'on
juge pas une mesure sur son efficacité.
on dit elle est bonne ou elle est
mauvaise. Donc là, on tombe dans la
morale. Malheureusement, ça ça nous tue
souvent. Euh en Europe, on y reviendra
plus tard. Mais euh la question
fondamentale, c'est "Est-ce que ça
marche ?"
Mais aujourd'hui, il faut l'avouer, les
rapports de force qu'il instaure sur le
plan du commerce international, depuis
qu'il les installe, ça fonctionne. Et
donc cette nouvelle manière de faire de
la diplomatie en terme de commerce
international, ça fonctionne. Ça
fonctionne parce que et bien finalement
c'est nouveau. Les gens sur cette sphère
là n'ont pas l'habitude de d'assumer des
rapports de force et donc ils cèdent. Et
deuxièmement, ça fonctionne parce que
imaginez-vous hein à un mois et demi
d'élection donc de mi-mandat aux
États-Unis, il peut affirmer "Je vous
amené de la croissance, je sais des
rapports de force donc je sais vous
défendre." Et donc alors que vous aviez
une situation quand même très fragile au
niveau politique au moment de son
élection, on peut estimer que ces deux
étages de la fusée fonctionnent et lui
donnent finalement une assise suffisante
pour continuer en fait son programme
America First. America first parce qu'il
a baissé les impôts pour favoriser en
fait le pouvoir d'achat des Américains.
America first parce qu'il a décidé non
que les États-Unis irraient plus vite
que les autres pour faire Amérique en
premier mais de faire plutôt tomber les
autres. Et finalement son programme
aujourd'hui économique et bien de
repositionner les États-Unis comme un
leader alors qu'elles avaient tendance à
perdre de leur influence au cours des
dernières années. Donc de redevenir un
leader en finalement fragilisant ses
partenaires. Et on va y venir tout à
l'heure la fragilisation en fait d'un
pays comme la Chine ça remet beaucoup de
choses en question. puisque ça fait à
peu près une quinzaine d'années que le
monde a changé à travers l'émergence de
la Chine comme une vraie puissance
économique mondiale puisque rappelons
qu'en 2000 avant son entrée dans l'OMC,
c'était un économique. Aujourd'hui,
c'est la première puissance
manufacturière au monde, la deuxème
économie mondiale. Et donc le fait
qu'elle puisse être fragilisée à travers
un changement fondamental des règles du
jeu, ça va semer du trouble et il est
probable que les tensions qui ont émergé
au cours du premier semestre perdurent
voire même s'exacerb et beaucoup
d'observateurs font le pari que ça va
s'arrêter après les élections de
mi-mandat. De manière évidente, c'est
pas le cas hein. C'est encore une fois
prendre ses rêves pour des réalités. Le
processus qui est en cours n'est pas un
processus ponctuel, c'est un processus
prévu et prévisible. Il est même
probable qu'après celui-ci euh il trouve
d'autres beau émissaires pour encore
renforcer sa popularité avec une optique
de réélection donc à la fin de son
premier mandat.
Attention, c'est un jeu dangereux.
C'est un jeu c'est un jeu dangereux
économiquement. C'est un jeu dangereux.
Pourquoi ? parce que euh depuis des
années et depuis la crise euh il y a eu
une mondialisation de l'économie qui a
fait que beaucoup d'entreprises
américaines sont allées s'installer en
Chine, au Japon et ailleurs. Donc quand
vous entrez en guerre avec la Chine,
vous entrez en guerre contre vous-même
aussi. C'est-à-dire que vous avez
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'industries et peu
de rapatriments manufacturiers
finalement aux États-Unis. C'est parce
que c'est le départ.
Et donc vous avez Oui, mais bon, on est
on y est. Et une usine ça se déplace pas
comme ça. Ça se déplace pas en un mois.
Donc vous avez encore euh Apple fabrique
ses téléphones ou pas dans la silicone
vallée, ça se ça se fabrique plutôt en
Chine
et ça s'assemble ça s'assemble en Chine
surtout. avant avant deè chose avant de
poursu
deè chose
je reviendrai après là
il faut euh il faut il faut bien euh
comprendre que la Chine a un gros
avantage c'est qu'ils ont mis la main
depuis quelques années sur tout ce qui
est terre rare.
Ils en ont le quasi monopole
à
80 90 % et que si ils ont envie à un
moment de répondre à monsieur Trump,
ça pourrait devenir très désagréable
pour l'industrie américaine. Je vous
rappelle que des terres rares, il y en a
partout,
hein. Ça va du pot
Non, si elles sont rares, il y en a pas
partout.
Ça va du Ça va du po catalytique. On en
a besoin partout.
Euh euh ça va du pot catalytique à tout
ce qui est électronique et cetera et
cetera. Et donc euh s'il s'amuse à faire
un embargo là-dessus, on peut avoir des
euh des suites euh amusantes sur le la
guerre commerciale qu'on peut avoir
entre les États-Unis et la Chine. Donc
c'est quelque chose si vous voulez où on
est tout à fait d'accord. Là pour
l'instant on est dans on est dans
l'opération de com mais comme dans
beaucoup de choses, on est politique, on
est dans l'opération de com. Donc il
prépare ses élections, on est dans
l'opération de com, il montre ses
muscles. OK. Maintenant,
ils peuvent aussi montrer leurs muscles
et pourrait avoir quelque chose
d'intéressant.
Sur ce plan sur ce plan, on n'est pas
complètement en phase parce que pour
nous, il y a bien plus que de la comie
volonté. Il faut pas oublier que comme
on disait tout à l'heure, la Chine
n'existait pas en 2001 d'un point de vue
économique. Elle n'existait pas. rien
des des exportations mondiales les
chinoises devaient représenter 2 % des
exportations les exportations chinoises
devaient représenter 2 % des export
exportation mondial on doit être à 13 %
aujourd'hui. Entre 25 et 30 % de la
production manufact manufacturière
mondiale est faite en Chine aujourd'hui
alors qu'on était proche de zéro à
l'époque. Donc il faut avoir en tête que
les phèines de délocalisation de
migration des entreprises ça existe. Ça
a été le cas à l'époque. Mais pourquoi
ça a été le cas ? C'est pour ça que je
souscris pas au fait que il n'est pas
possible de faire revenir des outils de
production.
Pas possible. J'ai dit que ça se fait
sur un temps long.
Oui.
Et que les élections c'est pas dans un
temps long.
Oui. Mais les
les élections c'est tous les 5 ans.
Mais la raison pour laquelle [rires] la
Chine a réussi, ce n'est pas à l'époque
vous savez hein, les délocalisations en
fait le moteur qu'on vous dit souvent
c'est ils ont délocalisé tout simplement
pour bénéficier de coûts de production
plus faible. Sauf que si ça suffisait
pour provoquer un énorme phénomène de
délocalisation, ça serait aujourd'hui
les entreprises seraient plus en Chine,
même Madagascar. Or, c'est pas le cas.
Et c'est là où c'est intéressant
pourquoi les Chinois réussi à l'époque
en terme économique et et ont généré cet
énorme phénomène de délocalisation qu'on
ait pas vu peut-être depuis un siècle
parce que ils ont offert d un coût de
production faible mais surtout la
promesse que ça allait durer pendant
longtemps. Et c'est là où où Trump
réussira ou non à faire relocaliser son
outil de production. Il est clair, comme
tu l'évoques jusque-l, si c'est de la
com, Apple ne considérera même pas le
fait de faire revenir en fait des outils
de production sur le territoire. Mais si
il affirme et qu'on comprend que cette
dynamique là, elle s'inscrit dans le
long terme et c'est un vrai objectif de
politique générale, à la alors les
entreprises qui ne sont ni morales ni
immorales qui sont à morales, ce sont
des coquilles qui ont la moralité de
leur gouvernance, considéreront à
nouveau l'importance finalement de
produire dans un lieu si on veut y
vendre. Parce que on a beau dire les
entreprises vont aujourd'hui on a
explosé la chaîne de production des
produits en faisant produit en fait dans
des pays à bas coup mais le consommateur
final reste bonhommant aux mêmes
endroits donc avec des pays à fort
pouvoir d'achat et les États-Unis
aujourd'hui restent le premier marché et
si les entreprises américaines veulent
continuer à pouvoir bénéficier de ce
premier marché là je suis à peu près
persuadé si Trump leur donne une
visibilité quant au fait que ces règlesl
sont pas là ponctuellement mais sont là
pour longtemps qu'on verra un phénomène
de de relocalisation finalement dans ces
territoires ou au moins dans des pays
qui lui sont plus proches. Donc faire
attention premièrement sur cette
capacité à relocaliser. Deuxièmement sur
les rapports de force. Bah c'est bien
beau mais on le voit là on a 260
milliards de produits taxés maintenant
de produits
importés de Chines qui sont taxés. La
réponse des Chinois automatique c'est au
mois de juillet et ben vous en faites
50, on en fait 50. Dire que moi aussi je
vais vous taxer 50 milliards des biens
portés en provenant des États-Unis. Là
les États-Unis font 200 milliards. Ils
font combien les Chinois ? Ils font 60.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'au total, ils
importent 130 milliards de dollars alors
que les Américains importent entre 5 et
600 milliards de dollars de produits
chinois. Ben voyez, de poids de mesure.
Donc à un moment donné, ils ont beau
dire je vais réagir, sauf que ils ont
plus de balles dans le barrier. Et donc
véritablement
ça c'est c'est un point de vue
fondamental. C'est où se se situe
aujourd'hui le rapport de force. Ça fait
une dizaine d'années qu'on dit les
États-Unis déclinent. À ce stade, le
premier marché au monde reste les
États-Unis avec des fondations certes
fragile, mais finalement pas plus
fragile qu'ailleurs dans les mondes dans
les pays matures. Et en face d'eux, ils
ont quoi ? Ils ont un pays comme la
Chine qui a véritablement explosé, qui
est beaucoup plus solide qu'en 2000 mais
qui reste avec de grosses fragilités. Tu
évoqué tout à l'heure le système
financier. Le système financier chinois
est extrêmement branlant. Euh le niveau
de dette euh total en Chine est
extraordinairement élevé et encore si on
prend en considération toute la dette
non officielle, là on explose les
records avec une économie qui tombe
beaucoup sur l'investissement à savoir
qui est très très cyclique donc encore
beaucoup sur les bouchées externes.
Alors certes, ils ont peut-être un
monopole sur les terres rares, en tout
cas une forte implantation là-dessus,
mais quand on fait objectivement le
point du rapport de force entre les
deux, je crois qu'on sous-estime un peu,
parce qu'on a peut-être envie de le
sous-estimer, la position dominante des
États-Unis actuels, elle reste encore
dominante. Et d'ailleurs, on pourrait
s'interroger. Est-ce que si Trump
n'avait rien fait, aujourd'hui, les
Chinois clairement ont conscience de ses
fragilités depuis quelques années. Ils
s'organisent pour y répondre, pour
consolider leur fondation. Mais c'est
pas encore fini. On en est loin de
l'avoir fini et ce qui fait que cette
attaque finalement frontale de la part
des États-Unis, c'est un peu le bon
timing. Si l'objectif des États-Unis,
c'est assurer leur leadership et
réaffirmer leur leadership au niveau
mondial, c'est le moment de le faire
parce qu'une fois effectivement que la
Chine aura consolidé son modèle
économique sera moins fragile, moins
financièrement dépendant, moins moins
dépendant des investissements, à partir
de là, le rapport de force serait
beaucoup plus équilibré. Il est évident
que les États-Unis auraient pas le
loisir de montrer les muscles comme ils
le font depuis le premier semestre.
Alors, il montre les muscles.
On va repartir là-dessus.
Non seulement il montre les muscles
économiquement puisque ils ont déclaré
une guerre commerciale,
mais
ça tombe à un moment où
il y a une grande fragilité et il y a
une grande fragilité financière.
Pourquoi cette grande fragilité
financière ? Je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure, on a inondé le monde de billets
de banque
plutôt vert mais après il y en a eu de
toutes les couleurs quand monsieur Dragy
s'y est mis. Mais
on a inondé le monde et on a inondé le
monde depuis 2008, depuis 2009
exactement où on a commencé à faire
tourner les imprimantes. Qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé ? Il s'est passé récemment
que vous avez eu beaucoup de mouvements
de capitaux. Pourquoi ? Parce que
cet argent qui a été créé pendant des
années, il est allé se placer dans des
endroits où il y avait encore un petit
peu de rendement, encore un petit peu de
croissance. Et c'était quoi ces pays-là
? C'était des pays en voie de
développement, c'est-à-dire en gros les
bricks, ce qu'on appelle les bricks. Et
donc cet argent est allé se placer
là-bas.
Sauf que [raclement de gorge]
j'ai, on a un collègue qui s'appelle
Albert Edwards qui avait dit à propos
des bricks, "It's a bloody ridiculous
investment concept".
Pourquoi ? Mais tout simplement parce
que quand il faut rentrer dans ces
marchés, ça ne pose jamais aucun
problème. Quand il faut en sortir, en
revanche, c'est comme si on mettait le
feu tout autour de cette salle et qu'on
bloquait les portes. Le premier, celui
qui est près de la porte là, il arrivera
à sortir. Tous les autres, il cram.
C'est pas le bol. Mais c'est un peu ce
qui est en train de se passer. C'est un
peu ce suivi l'Argentine,
le Brésil, la Turquie.
Euh mais ça va nous amener petit à petit
à l'Europe, donc il faut pas le faire
tout de suite. Euh et donc la Turquie et
d'autres pays qui aujourd'hui sont en
difficulté sont en difficulté
financière. Pourquoi ? Parce que
l'argent repart et en emportant
évidemment à chaque fois les monnaies et
un certain nombre de problèmes sur les
taux d'intérêt et cetera.
C'est dangereux. C'est très dangereux
parce que
le le la voie qui est pour l'instant euh
conduite par les banques centrales qui
est de faire un peu semblant de réduire
leur bilan, c'est un peu semblant parce
qu'on y va vraiment à tout petit pas et
en précisant bien qu'au moindre problème
on reviendra parce qu'il faut quand même
rassurer mais ça ne suffit pas à lutter
contre la sortie des capitaux et La
sortie des capitaux pourrait très bien
déstabiliser aujourd'hui certains pays
qui peuvent entraîner derrière une une
mini catastrophe financière. Je vous
rappelle par exemple, c'est c'est un
tout petit exemple mais je vous rappelle
que les banques européennes sont par
exemple assez exposées à la Turquie.
Vous avez une banque comme la BNP est
exposée à hauteur de 35 milliards même,
c'est pas rien. 35 milliards, c'est la
moitié de ses fonds propres hein. De
mémoire, c'est 70 milliards, il me
semble. Donc c'est la moitié de ses
fonds propres, rien que ça. Et donc ces
35 milliards sont en risque en Turquie
avec une monnaie qui a joyeusement
baissé de 50 %. Donc ça peut faire très
mal. Donc attention à ça parce que ça
arrive en plus de la guerre commerciale
qui va déjà fragiliser ces pays et donc
on pourrait avoir des petites
catastrophes qui se préparent gentiment
et ça c'est un vrai changement
fondamental. Alors pour revenir sur les
raisons parce que tout à l'heure on
parlait des États-Unis, là tu pars sur
les émergents. La réalité c'est que là
encore l'épicentre du séisme qui est en
train de se produire, c'est un peu
lointain probablement vous l'avez pas
trop entendu mais l'Argentine
s'effondre. Là c'est c'est pas une
projection, c'est pas décliner, c'est
véritablement il y a un vrai
effondrement économique. La Turquie é en
grande difficulté. Le Brésil plus grand
pays, un peu plus résilient donc résiste
mais véritablement fragilisé. La plupart
des pays émergents en fait souffrent
directement en conséquence de quoi ? Des
États-Unis. Et là encore, on peut
s'interroger sur le fait du hasard.
C'estàd que euh là tu on évoquait juste
avant euh le la dynamique euh des taxes
douanières qui fragilisent leur débouché
externe, c'estàdire le modèle économique
central des pieds émergents. Mais en
parallèle, il faut avoir en tête que ce
qu'a fait Donald Trump, alors pourquoi
on dit maintenant les les pays émergents
bénéficient plus d'assez de liquidité
pour financer leur économie. Ça
concrètement c'est la conséquence de la
politique américaine, politique
budgétaire d'une part parce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure on baisse les impôts.
Alors c'est génial, on rase gratis sauf
qu'on rase pas complètement gratis. La
conséquence des baisses d'impôts,
lorsqu'elles sont très importantes et
qu'elles se retrouvent pas complètement
dans les dans les dépenses des ménages
et les investissements des entreprises,
ça génère quoi d'après vous ? Une chose
qu'on a dont on a horreur en Europe,
c'est presque un gros mot de le dire, du
déficit public. Déficit public, ça veut
dire qu'en gros, vous dépensez plus que
vous ne gagnez. Ben ça faut le financer.
C'està dire que aujourd'hui les besoins
de financement, la réforme, la baisse
des impôts aux États-Unis, elle
nécessite un financement. Qui c'est qui
paye d'après vous ?
Jusqu'à maintenant, c'était la banque
centrale américaine qui était dans la
CAF qui imprimait des billets de banque.
Donc c'était pratique dire que je
dépense plus, je finance le déficit avec
les billets qui sortent de la cave. Bon,
alors les gens sont amusants. Je don une
interview ce midi et la question c'était
est-ce que la banque centrale américaine
est indépendante ? Enfin, il y a bien
que nous pour croire qu'une banque
centrale est véritablement indépendante
du de du pouvoir politique. Ça peut
exister pendant 10 ans, 15 ans, 20 ans
quand tout va bien. Mais dès que ça va
mal, on sait très bien qu'on ne peut pas
avoir une dissociation entre la
politique monétaire et la politique
budgétaire. Enfin, on peut faire
semblant en fait de de le croire mais ça
dure jamais bien longtemps. Mais jusque-
là, on avait quoi ? On avait des
déficits publics financés par la machine
à imprimer les billets de banque. Aux
États-Unis, on nimprime plus. Alors, ça
reviendra peut-être mais pour l'instant,
on nimprime plus. on imprime de moins en
moins, c'est-à dire qu'on injecte plus
de liquidité et donc il faut trouver
l'argent pour financer ces déficits
ailleurs et on les trouve où d'ailleurs
? ailleurs. C'est là le problème, c'est
vraiment ça, c'est que
la conséquence finalement de la déviance
de la politique budgétaire américaine,
ce ne sont pas les États-Unis qui
empathissent, c'est directement les pays
émergents. Parce que jusque-là, le surpu
liquidité, il allait s'investir et être
supporté par les économies émergentes.
Maintenant, vu qu'on a un besoin de
financement public plus important aux
États-Unis, ben qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Les fonds vont directement le financer.
Ça, c'est au détriment des autres. Et
donc, on a un vrai phénomène qui a
changé au cours du premier semestre. Il
faut l'avoir en tête qu'il y a vraiment
deux dimensions.
Cette dynamique financière là, c'est un
vrai changement depuis 10 ans et ça va
fragiliser de manière déterminante les
pays émergents, le Brésil, la Russie,
l'Inde, la Chine et cetera. France, bon,
on y viendra tout à l'heure. Euh
premièrement et le deuxième la deuxième
salve qui est une attaque frontale
également, c'est qu'en plus de ce risque
financier, vous avez le risque
économique à travers la guerre
commerciale déclarée depuis le premier
semestre. Donc si tout cela alors bien
sûr si vous le prenez en silo, vous les
mettez les uns à côté les autres, h ces
phénomènes-là, on peut considérer que
c'est complètement le fait du hasard,
mais si vous les rassemblez ensemble et
vous prenez de la hauteur tout de suite
ça s'inscrit à mon sens beaucoup plus
dans un programme très précis d'America
First avec encore une fois, il y a deux
manières de le faire. Soit j'avance plus
vite que les autres, soit je fais tomber
les autres. Et il y a une vraie
politique aujourd'hui qui amène à la
fragilisation des autres, d'une partie
du monde, d'une partie du monde
émergent. N'oublions pas quand même que
une grande partie de la croissance
depuis 15 ans, elle vient d'où ? Pas de
la France, même pas de l'Allemagne, mais
elle vient des pays émergents. Donc
attention, on a là véritablement, c'est
pas des prédictions, on est en train de
constater le fait que la locomotive
mondiale est en train de ralentir
fortement et la question de fond c'est
quelles vont être les conséquences
derrière ? Alors, dans les conséquences
derrière, on a fait un petit parallèle
en en revenant dans l'histoire en
arrière. Euh on est en train de
constater quand même euh que les les
finalement les
la puissance publique est de plus en
plus
instable et et et
a beaucoup beaucoup moins de moyens
qu'avant.
Et donc
il y a un phénomène qui est intéressant,
c'est de voir de plus en plus des
entreprises, ce qu'on appelle les gafas
aux États-Unis, des entreprises
Facebook, Amazon et cetera, Google
et autres qui
deviennent plus puissantes que l'État,
plus puissante en CCH, plus puissant
finalement
en en massage de données plus puissante.
Il commence à donner des conseils
en pouvoir d'influence. Il commence à
envoyer des lettres à monsieur Trump
pour lui dire ce qu'il faut faire. Et
ça, si on se souvient bien, ça s'est
déjà passé. Et ça a abouti à quoi ? Au
démantellement
h
de ces sociétés. Mais alors tu fais
référence, tu fais référence à la fin du
19e, c'est ça ? Début du 20e. Aux
États-Unis, on fait un tout petit
parallèle historique parce que c'est
intéressant. L'histoire se répète
rarement mais rime souvent tout de même.
Il faut le faut l'avoir en tête. Fin du
19e. Effectivement ça c'est une période
qui ressemble beaucoup à la période
actuelle. On a un système où on a eu une
innovation technologique majeure,
machine à vapeur qui permet en fait en
gros une vraie révolution dans les
transports plus euh télégraphe, donc une
révolution à la fois dans les
transports, à la fois dans la
communication qui permet en fait de
gérer et de générer le premier phénomène
de délocalisation de l'histoire puisque
pour la première fois on peut produire
un endroit autre je dirais ailleurs en
fait du lieu où on consomme. Donc ça
c'est c'est extraordinaire au départ. Ça
crée de l'emploi, ça crée de la
croissance le temps en fait qu'on ait
digéré finalement cette ces innovations
technologiques. Donc beaucoup de
croissance, même si on a un système
illégalitaire, quand on a beaucoup de
croissance, c'est pas grave parce que
même si vous en touchez quelques
miettes, vous êtes toujours dans
l'espoir d'en toucher quelques miettes.
Donc ce qui est important, c'est que
lorsqu'on est dans un environnement de
croissance important, on sait que les
systèmes inégalitaires sont assez
supportés par la population.
Malheureusement, lorsque la croissance
disparaît, et bien la capacité de la
population à supporter ces systèmes
inégalitaires là devient de moins en
moins importantes. Et au 19e siècle,
c'est ce qui s'est produit. D'ailleurs,
je rappelle hein, on avait les mêmes
tensions actuelles, troubles politique,
troubles géopolitique avec des vastes
phases de terrorisme à l'époque
d'origine anarchiste, émergence du
syndicalisme et cetera et cetera, avec
des tensions sociales très fortes au
sein de au sein de la population qui
traduisait simplement le fait que la
croissance ayant disparue et bien le
système assez inégalitaire en terme de
partage de la richesse est de moins en
moins supporté. C'était vrai dans tous
les pays riches de l'époque, y compris
c'est vrai aujourd'hui
et et c'est vrai aujourd'hui y compris
aux États-Unis. Et et ce à quoi tu
faisais référence à l'époque, c'est la
manière dont les États-Unis avaient
répondu à ce système. Est-ce que vous
savez quelle était la réponse qu'on ont
fait les États-Unis à un système
inégalitaire qui n'était plus supporté
par la population
et dont l'origine était essentiellement
le fait que certains agents privés,
certaines entreprises devenaient des
concurrents légitimes de l'État.
l'élection de Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous
avez Oui. [rires] Non mais oui, il faut
le dire.
Pardon ? Pon âme 1901 l'élection de
Théodore Rosevelt. Le programme de
Théodore Roosevelt consiste
essentiellement à dire je découperai les
gros. C'est en 1901. Et donc au bout
d'un moment, il faut avoir en tête que
lorsque la croissance disparaît,
les inégalités en fait structurelles
générées par un modèle qui pouvait être
accepté à une époque ne le deviennent
plus derrière. Et donc ça peut générer
soit une réponse progressiste, la France
l'avait été à l'époque hein, loi 1901,
loi 1905, euh le fait que les
agriculteurs se regroupent autour de
banque comme le créat école
centre-france euh centre-fance parce que
je viens d'Auvergne très important à la
pour financer en fait leurs activités,
la France avait été assez progressiste
pour répondre en fait à ces troubles de
l'époque. Les États-Unis ont été
beaucoup plus dans la rupture parce
qu'ils ne supportaient plus le fait que
certains comme Rockfeller devenaient des
concurrents légitimes de l'État. Et donc
on arrive vers une décennie qui est une
qui est une décennie de lutte fratricide
qui aboutit en 1911 à euh aux lois
antitrust qui fait que concrètement ces
entreprises-là sont découpées. Si on
fait référence à cela, c'est que dans le
America first, on l'a dit tout à l'heure
et c'est pas au monde militaire qu'on va
l'apprendre. En géopolitique, quand ça
va mal à l'intérieur, on cherche des
bouqu émissaires. On l'a dit, Donald
Trump en a trouvé de manière évidente,
vous nous spoilez, vous pays étrangers
qui exportez vers notre pays. Donc, on a
trouvé la Chine, on a trouvé les pays
qui exportaient finalement vers les
États-Unis. Premier bouqu émissaire, ça
va pas durer. Après, derrière, il faudra
en trouver d'autres. Et et ce que dit
Olivier, c'est qu'il est probable que
dans la deuxième phase du mandat de
Donald Trump, le bouc émissaire ne soit
pas à l'extérieur mais soit plutôt à
l'intérieur et que on pourra en
reparler, mais il ne serait pas du tout
impossible que lorsque le patron d'Apple
envoie une lettre pour dire ce qu'il
faut faire à Donald Trump, il commette
une erreur fondamentale. Lorsque
l'ensemble des conglomarats américains
se rassemblent au mois de septembre dans
un lobby unique, ils font probablement
une erreur fondamentale parce qu'ils
s'identifi eux et en s'identifiant entre
eux, il légitime le fait que c'est ce
sont des conglomérats qui existent et
qui bénéficient essentiellement du
système construit au cours de la
dernière décennie ou des dernières
décennies. Et ils deviennent quoi en
réalité en se rassemblant monde
militaire ? Ils deviennent une cible.
Donc voilà, puisque la réforme fiscale,
les baisses d'impôts, ça apporte de la
croissance, mais on le sait très bien à
court terme et dans quelques trimestres,
elle va disparaître. la capacité de la
population américaine de à supporter un
système très inégalitaire ne va pas
augmenter. Il est probable qu'on arrive
vers une deuxième phase de tension qui
sera bien plus complexe et qui remettra
en cause le deuxième pilier de la
croissance mondiale depuis 15 ans, à
savoir le premier qui était le phénomène
de délocalisation, le deuxième celui qui
de quelques grands groupes qui emporte
toute la mise hein puisque vous savez
que l'essentiel en fait des entreprises
enfin ces entreprises là les gafas sont
tellement grosses que même si
aujourd'hui elles bénéficie d'un
avantage technologique même si c'était
pas le cas c'est pas grave parce
qu'elles sont tellement gorgées de
liquidité de cash que si il y a une
innovation, il sont en capacité de la
racheter systématiquement.
Donc vous voyez, donc on est vraiment
dans une situation où euh lorsqu'on se
projette, la question c'est on sait pas
on sait pas comment les règles du jeu
vont évoluer, mais ce qu'il est ce qu'on
peut constater, c'est que ces
tensions-là ne sont pas d'origine
conjoncturelle. Elles répondent à des
changements structurels. Nos normes, nos
règles du jeu depuis 15 ans sont en
train de changer et ne considérons pas
que ça soit simplement l'humeur de
Donald Trump qui aboutisse à cela.
c'est quelque chose de mondial.
C'est-à-dire que c'est en effet un vrai
changement structurel. C'est le
potentiel de croissance et c'est le
potentiel de croissance dans toutes les
zones. Vous avez ce potentiel de
croissance qui se réduit depuis à peu
près les années 50 si l'on veut faire
large et en gros d'un % tous les 10 ans.
Donc c'est vrai que vous avez démarré
très haut, vous avez démarré autour de
7.
Alors, vous enlevez 1 % par dizaine
d'années,
il reste plus grand-chose. Ça veut dire
quoi ? Ça veut dire que en effet le
gâteau a cessé de croître.
Pour beaucoup de raisons, ce gâteau
structurellement cessé de croître. Donc
ça va amener en effet des
bouleversements.
On parlait de de je crois que l'année
dernière on avait on avait parlé de la
Chine en disant finalement c'était ça
fonctionnait sur un espèce de contrat
avec la population et en effet
on leur disait on va vous faire les
dirigeants chinois leur disaient on va
vous faire de la croissance 7 8 % 10 %
croissance à deux chiffres
et nous on va se gaver en tant que
dirigeant chinois mais vous aurez les
miettes et les miettes de d'une
croissance à deux chiffres, c'est quand
même de très jolies miettes. C'est des
miettes très dorées. Ça suffit à faire
rêver.
Ça suffit à faire rêver et ça donc
suffit à tenir la population en respect.
Le seul petit souci, c'est quand cette
croissance passe de 10 12 comme on l'a
connu à certains certaines époques, à 3.
3, c'est en Chine, c'est une récession
hein. C'est c'està-dire que ça ne suffit
absolument pas à absorber
tout ce qui vient des campagnes et qui
arrive dans les villes avec l'espoir un
jour de d'arriver à un niveau de vie
occidental.
À trois ils arrivent plus, hein. Tr ils
y arrivent plus. et même il retourne en
général dans les campagnes.
Vous êtes en récession à 3 % en Chine,
vous êtes en récession. Et ça ça veut
dire quoi ? Ben ça veut dire que le
contrat le petit contrat qu'on avait
signé au départ où on disait vous allez
avoir les miettes de beaucoup de
croissance, il est plus là. Et donc et
ça c'est quand même dans beaucoup de
pays.
Vous avez alors les Chinois c'est trois
nous ça va bientôt être zéro euh
peut-être zéro plus ou zéro moins.
Alors c'est progressif. La baisse
[raclement de gorge] de la croissance
potentielle en réalité, elle se trad
elle elle vient pas de l'extérieur hein.
Pourquoi on Pourquoi vous vous pourrez
enfin vous pouvez éventuellement être
surpris quand vous dit ça mais qu'est-ce
qui se passe ? Ils sont déclinistes ?
Non, on n'est pas des clinistes. En
réalité, il faut comprendre que la
croissance qu'on génère, la tas du
gâteau qu'on se partage, elle correspond
essentiellement euh à notre à nos
comportements, nos comportements de
consommateur. Or en réalité, ce qui se
passe, c'est la révolution dont personne
ne parle systématiquement. Vous en avez
parlé, on en avait parlé l'année
dernière, c'est une révolution de
moyens, la technologie qui permet de
faire les choses différemment. Donc ça
va tout changer mais mais ça change rien
en terme de déboucher. Et une révolution
de débouché qui vient directement de
notre nos notre propre changement à
travers notre vieillissement. Et en
réalité c'est cela euh qui explique le
la baisse tendantielle de l'augmentation
de la taille du gâteau à se partagé. Un
pays qui vieillit simplement est un pays
qui ne peut pas espérer, qui voit sa sa
sa croissance potentielle de la
consommation des ménages décroître
progressivement. Alors, je vous rappelle
qu'il n'y a qu'un seul continent qui
n'est pas concerné par ce vieillissement
de la population et par cette baisse de
la démographie, c'est l'Afrique.
Le reste, que ce soit la Chine, le
Japon, on en parle même plus parce que
ils sont
on en parle plus parce qu'aujourd'hui
ils sont 125 millions de personnes et la
projection de 90 en 2050.
Voilà. Et c'est ça vient pas de chez
nous hein, ça vient de du ministère de
la santé au Japon. Faire
confiance. C'est un/3. En Italie, c'est
pareil.
En Espagne, c'est pareil. Nous sommes
sur des taux de fécondité qui sont à 130
alors que c'est 210 pour espérer
remplacer la population.
À terme, c'est un suicide, on peut le
dire.
Donc c'est un suicide. C'est un suicide
en Grèce, c'est un suicide en Italie,
c'est un suicide en Espagne, c'est
bientôt un suicide en France parce que
ne croyez pas que on claironne depuis
des années que avec notre formidable
système, nous sommes à plus de 10. Non,
on est à 1,0 donc on est en dessous de
210.
Alors, on est moins frappé que les
autres sur ce plan. Tant mieux. On a
géré le vieillissement des baby boomers,
mais sur ce plan, on est quand même
mieux
faut bien faut bien qu'on gagne quelque
part.
Euh et donc
on a ce phénomène, on a ce phénomène en
Chine, on a ce phénomène en Russie. En
Russie, il y aura 20 plus de 20 millions
de Russes de moins en 2050 par rapport à
la population actuelle.
Quand vous save que 2 tiers la richesse
concrée repose sur la consommation des
ménages. Quand vous avez 20 millions de
personnes en moins, vous ne pouvez pas
espérer en fait que l'augmentation de la
consommation des gens qui restent se
substituent en fait à ce manque à
gagner. Et donc il faut avoir en tête
que là aussi la disparition de la
croissance ce n'est pas de l'idéologie,
ce n'est pas du dogme. C'est simplement
et c'est important qu'on fait de la
prospective de rester sur les faits.
C'est simplement la traduction de nos
propres changements. Nous avons été
portés par un phénomène tout autre
pendant 30 à 40 ans qui explique
d'ailleurs les trend glorieuses de
l'époque hein et ces niveaux de
croissance formidable. Progressivement
elles disparaissent. Et simplement
pourquoi c'est maintenant que ça a un
impact ? Parce que fondamentalement et
c'est aussi vrai pour le chef les chefs
d'entreprises que nous sommes de petites
entreprises que nous sommes, c'est ce
qui est intéressant c'est que lorsque on
est porté par l'essort de son secteur
d'activité
qui augmente naturellement, bah même si
vous avez des problèmes en interne, un
modèle pas totalement efficace, c'est
pas grave parce que vous gagnez
suffisamment pour avoir le loisir de ne
pas régler le problème. Ça c'est
fondamental. Psychologiquement, nous
fabriquons des leaders, des chefs qui
n'ont pas besoin, qui ne sont pas dans
la nécessité impérieuse de régler les
problèmes. Ils ont les moyens de les
mettre sous le tapis. À partir du moment
où vous n'êtes plus porté par les sorts
de votre secteur, même sans qu'il se
décline, il reste stable. Vous êtes dans
une situation où si vous avez un
problème, si vous avez un modèle
inefficace ou si vous voulez même
continuer à croître, et bien il va
falloir poser des arbitrages, prendre
des décisions. Vous quelqu'un, ça sera
en défaveur de quelqu'un d'autre. C'est
beaucoup plus difficile et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le moment dans lequel on
se trouve, c'est un moment qui est
d'abord difficile intellectuellement à
assumer parce que nous avons fabriqué
pendant quatre décennies des
gestionnaires qui n'avaient pas qui
n'avaient besoin qui avaient simplement
besoin de gérer un modèle efficace,
moins efficace, c'est pas grave. On
avait les moyens de le maintenir et
aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus ces
moyensl donc il ne faut plus des
gestionnaires, il faut des leaders.
alors une dizaine d'années hein pour
réinventer les modèles mais ça c'est pas
de la même nature. Et donc on vit en
fait et d'ailleurs on pourrait revenir
sur les signaux que nous envoie les
votes politiques partout dans le monde
dans les pays riches partout. En gros,
ces signaux qui sont des signaux en fait
de de rupture ou de prémise de rupture
ne sont que l'expression de la
conscience de la population d'un modèle
inadapté et d'aujourd'hui de notre
incapacité à le réinventer ou en tout
cas à faire confiance aux gens qui se
proposent pour le réinventer. Et là
encore, c'est toujours important d'avoir
en tête lorsqu'on est dans les chiffres,
on passe pas mal dans les médias, on
nous demande toujours ce qui va se
passer la semaine prochaine, le mois
prochain, le trimestre prochain. Aucun
intérêt. Là, la question fondamentale,
c'est est-ce que ce que nous vivons
maintenant depuis quelques années est
finalement anecdotique ? Si c'est le
cas, d'ailleurs n'en parlons pas parce
que naturellement, il va disparaître ou
est-ce qu'il est plus structurel ? Et ce
qui est important à voir en tête, on
était là l'année dernière, on vous
alouré sur ce qui pouvait arriver depuis
l'année dernière. Les choses ont encore
changé. Et malheureusement, l'histoire
récente nous donne raison. dire que ces
changements sont les conséquences de
d'un modèle inadapté à un monde qui est
en train de changer. Et donc tant qu'on
aura pas réussi à le réinventer, à le
recréer et ça passera probablement par
des générations de personnes qui soient
fondamentalement différente des
précédentes, on vivra en fait des
ruptures qui seront des ruptures qui
vont s'accumuler et donc les tensions
actuelles ne sont pas momentanées, elles
sont structurelles et se projeter en
imaginant qu'elles font se régler
d'elles-mêmes, c'est probablement un
pari que à titre personnel je ne ferai
pas.
Et toi ?
Pas du tout.
Euh non, ce qui ce qui est ce qui est
terrifiant aujourd'hui, c'est de voir
justement l'incapacité des gens qui nous
dirigent, des politique. Quand je dis
nous, c'est mondial, hein, c'est pas je
ne je ne je ne vous parle pas simplement
de la France, mais justement adresser
ces problèmes là. Vous n'entendez jamais
parler du vieillissement et de et de la
de la démographie. C'est un sujet quasi
tabou. Pourquoi ? Bah parce qu'ils ont
pas la solution. et qu'aujourd'hui si
vous regardez ne serait-ce que là on va
on va peut-être arriver sur la sur la
France mais quand vous regardez des
aujourd'hui qu'on a
je je ça ça m'amuse
on va s'arrêter en Italie
euh on va on va faire un petit passage
en Italie avant mais quand vous regardez
ce que ça va donner sur les sur les
retraites et donc sur la consommation et
donc sur la croissance quand vous
regardez ce que ce que ça va donner sur
les retraites on vous dit toujours B, on
va repousser d'un an, de 2 ans l'âge de
départ à la retraite. Mais c'est pas le
sujet. Le sujet, il est loin d'être là.
Je sais pas si vous savez, mais il y a
quelques temps au Japon pour les les
personnes publiques, enfin pour les
fonctionnaires, on a repoussé le le
l'âge de la retraite à 80 ans.
Voilà.
Là, ils viennent de prendre un coup là.
Là, il vient de prendre un coup là.
Là, là, de manière évidente, la salle
réagit plus. On les a perdu.
J'ai un copain qui a
une filiale au Japon.
Il a cinq commerciaux.
La moyenne d'âge c'est 67 ans de ces
commerciaux. D'accord. Donc ça veut dire
quoi ? Ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on va
vers une société où
vous ne prendrez pas votre retraite
à 65 ans.
La deuxième chose c'est que vous
continuerez à travailler parce que vous
n'aurez pas le choix. C'est ce qui se
passe aux États-Unis d'ailleurs. Le la
seule catégorie de population qui a
récupéré son taux de de participation à
la population active, c'est la classe
des âges de plus de 65 ans
qui sont obligés en complément de leur
retraite de travailler et d'avoir
plusieurs boulots.
Et la troisième chose c'est que vous
vendrez vos actifs.
Oui,
un ménage américain en moyenne quand il
part à la retraite, il a 225000 dollars.
C'est une moyenne, c'est pas une
médiane. Donc vous avez Bill Gates et
compagnie qui a fait légèrement
augmenter cette cette moyenne. Donc ils
partent avec 225000 dollars. Combien
leur coûte leur frais de santé ? Juste
leur frais de santé, ils mangent pas,
ils vivent pas mais juste leur frais de
santé jusqu'à leur mort.
275000 dollars, ils sont déjà en l'air
de 50000.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? Ils
s'endettent, ils ont pas le choix. Et
donc on est dans un système qui ne
pourra marcher que sur la dette.
Alors non, ça c'est parce que on a
finalement pas pris la mesure que nos
propres changements ne nous autorisent
plus à utiliser les mêmes modèles
qu'avant. La réalité c'est que il y a
deux manières de faire. C'est pourquoi
on vous parle de ça ? C'est dire que le
préalable à la reconstruction, c'est le
bon diagnostic. Vous allez voir le
médecin, si vous posez le mauvais
diagnostic, le traitement ne sera pas
bon. Et une des erreurs probablement et
d'ailleurs on les com on la commet plus
en Europe qu'ailleurs, c'est que nous
avons ou nous posons des diagnostics et
beaucoup trop de dogmes sous-jacent ou
d'idéologie. Factuellement, il faut
comprendre qu'il pour des raisons
structurelles qui nous sont qui sont en
fait nos propres caractéristiques, nous
ne pouvons plus supporter les modèles
d'entemp. Et donc il faut là pour le
coup on parle beaucoup, vous savez de de
jolis mots de disruption aujourd'hui. La
réalité c'est que la disruption elle
d'abord être intellectuelle et se dire
que nous devons reconstruire un modèle
adapté à cela. Et quand tu évoques en
fait la notion de seigneor la réalité et
là il faut dire la vérité on s'en fiche
de l'âge de départ à la retraite parce
que les gens ne voudront pas partir
parce que l'équilibre démographi fixe
non parce que toi tu le présentes comme
une comme une fatalité. Donc c'est dire
que concrètement augmenter l'âge de
départ à la retraite ça ne sert à rien.
Vous savez combien à l'âge de la
liquidation de la retraite en France que
vous savez combien de personnes sont au
chômage chez nous ? À peu près 35 %.
vous pouvez augmenter l'âge de départ à
la retraite. Dire que en gros vous
déshabillerez Paul pour habiller
Jacques. Donc la question c'est plutôt
celui de l'emploi des seigneurs et
au-delà au-delà de ça, si on est honnête
et qu'on reprend pas en fait les
conclusions du conseil d'orientation des
retraites en France qui concrètement met
dans les paramètres de l'équation,
désolé il faut le dire quand même dans
les paramètres de l'équation des
paramètres qui sont complètement loufo
qui sont inaccessibles en fait pour
l'économie française. Donc vous faites
le constat que de fait sans même faire
des réformes supplémentaires, les taux
de remplacement c'estàd que le niveau de
retraite par rapport à celle par rapport
au niveau actuel vont baisser de 10 15
20 25 %. C'est ni bien ni pas bien.
C'est comme ça. C'est pour équilibrer
l'équation. Soit on fait de la dette,
soit on on le on l'impacte finalement
dans les revenus des des gens qui
pourraient partir à la retraite. Alors
faut pas les empêcher de partir à la
retraite. Faut simplement faire le
constat que ces gens qui voudront
maintenir leur niveau de vie devront
compléter leur revenu issus de leur
retraite. C'est ni grave ni pas grave.
Ça veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire qu'on
va pas forcer les gens à rester. Ils
auront le choix. Soit ils se satisferont
de moins, soit ils voudront compléter
leur revenus. Et donc la mission de la
société, c'est pas toujours de
caricaturer, dire qu'un seigneur en
emploi prend le boulot en fait d'un
jeune, c'est une sautise absolue. La
mission de la société, c'est finalement
de répondre aux besoins d'emploi des
seiors. Alors, on peut hausser les
épaules, sauf qu'en fait ce constat là,
il n'est pas posé. Parce que si c'est
véritablement le cas, et bien vous
faites vous construisez un marché du
travail qui va être spécifique aux gens
qui veulent compléter le revenu, qui ont
finalement des des volontés ou des
besoins qui sont très différents. Un
temps disponible, une une capacité
physique disponible, voilà, ou à
disposition, même des vélités de
compléments de revenus qui sont
différentes. Et dans ces cas-là, il faut
pas vouloir traiter tout le monde
pareil. Il faut traiter le marché des
seigneurs. Si on veut justement répondre
à cela, le marché du travail des seniors
à part entière. Il faut faire qu'une
entreprise puisse embaucher un seigneur.
Il faut aussi faire comprendre et vous
faire finalement comprendre dans la
société qu'il y a un message qui est
véhiculé qui d'une sautise absolue ou
quand on vous dit qu'un seigneur qui
reste en emploi, parce que c'est notre
société est très culpabilisante, un
seigneur qui reste en emploi prendrait
la place d'un jeune. Alors ça ça c'est
insupportable parce qu'en réalité c'est
vraiment ne rien comprendre en économie.
Un seior qui ne travaille plus est un
seigneur qui gagne moins. Si vous avez
compris que la richesse concrée dans
notre pays après tous les pays du monde
repose sur les dépenses des ménages, un
seigneur qui gagne moins est un seigneur
donc qui va moins dépenser et moins
créer de richesse. En réalité, le
seigneur qui reste en emploi gagne plus
que s'il ne travaillait plus. S'il gagne
plus, il a la capacité à assouvir plus
de besoins. Sauvabilité, son pouvoir
d'achat notamment en service va
augmenter et puisqu'il a plus de moyens
pour payer les services, et bien il y a
des entreprises qui en face vont pouvoir
être créées pour répondre à ce besoin
sollevable de services notamment des
seigneurs. Et vous savez qui c'est qui
les fait ces services en général ? Des
jeunes qualifiés ou non qualifiés ?
Plutôt non qualifiés. Vous savez où sont
les deux poches de chômage enfance ?
C'est pour ça que j'aime bien dire en
conférence
un petit peu provocateur que la France
choisit le chômage parce qu'elle est
caricaturelle dans sa dans sa vision des
choses. Les deux poches de chômage,
c'est chez les seigneurs et chez les
jeunes non qualifiés parce que ça part
du principe qu'un seigneur en emploi
prend la place d'un jeune. C'est d'une
sautise absolue et ça nous prive de la
capacité à répondre aux besoins. Alors
aujourd'hui c'est moins le cas parce que
les niveaux des retraites est suffisant
à l'heure actuelle pour à peu près
permettre au seigneur de pas compléter
leur revenus sans réforme
supplémentaire. ça sera plus le cas en
2030. Donc vous savez qu'il va avoir un
appétit pour le travail donc pour les
seigneurs et donc le choix que nous
aurons à faire c'est soit on s'organise
pour y répondre. Voyez, c'est ça en fait
le moteur du changement, c'est poser un
diagnostic, savoir qui en est, quels
sont nos besoins, est-ce que ces besoins
là changent ? Oui. Non. Et si oui,
s'organiser pour pouvoir y répondre. Et
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
aujourd'hui on n'y arrive pas parce
qu'on continue de caricaturer. On vous
dit la problème des retraites ou des
retraités, c'est d'ailleurs drôle.
retraiter ça fait passer un peu à
Zaratou. On a l'impression qu'au-delà
d'un certain âge, on sort de la société,
on remonte sur sa montagne et on regarde
la société de loin. Ce qui une vision
totalement caricaturale. La réalité
c'est que aujourd'hui, il y a pas d'âge
pour travailler. On travaille pour
répondre à un besoin. Et donc c'est
plutôt le degré d'activité en fonction
de son âge qu'il faut adresser. Il faut
arrêter de caricaturer avec l'opposition
systématique, actif, inactif, retraité
personne en âge de travail.
Alors, puisqu'on parle de la retraite,
on va parler de l'Italie que je vous ai
dit qu'elle vieillissait vite. C'est le
deuxième pays derrière l'Allemagne en
Europe qui vieillit extrêmement vite.
On va vous parler de l'Italie. Pourquoi
? Parce que il y a eu il y a
[raclement de gorge] quelques quelques
mois l'arrivée d'un gouvernement italien
un peu disruptif.
Hybrid hybride
hybride euh c'est euh pour vous donner
une idée, c'est Mélenchon et Marine Le
Pen ensemble. si vous voulez qui font un
petit
s'appelle Salvini. [rires]
Donc euh c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez euh étrange, une chimère presque
euh où en tout cas beaucoup de beaucoup
de gens ont voulu que ce soit une
Chimère, mais c'est arrivé. Et cette
Italie aujourd'hui est en passe de
mener le le leader le leadership
du souverainisme, on va dire.
Et [raclement de gorge]
il y a quelque chose qui est intéressant
parce que
je me souviens, je parlais avec des
Italiens, une famille italienne et puis
avant les élections
il me disait "Mais non mais de toute
façon le M5S et la Ligue seront jamais
élus".
Ils ont été élus. Puis après, ils m'ont
dit "Oh ils arriveront jamais à
s'allier."
Puis ils sont alliés et puis après, ils
m'ont dit "Mais ils feront jamais un
gouvernement."
Ils ont fait un gouvernement. Puis
après, ils m'ont dit "De toute façon, au
bout d'un mois, ça va sauter."
Ça fait tr
ça fait tr et donc
et je leur dis maintenant la prochaine
étape quoi ? C'est une sortie de l'euro.
Non, je suis pas bien sûr que dans
quelques mois je leur
[raclement de gorge] dise pas Ouais,
c'était pas sûr mais c'est quand même
arrivé. Pourquoi ? On a quand même
l'impression depuis plusieurs mois que
Salvini est en train de nous faire un
tour de magie. Vous savez le principe de
la magie ? J' gite la main droite. Vous
regardez tous ma main droite et pendant
ce temps-là, je pique le portefeuille de
Pierre dans sa poche gauche.
Chauvernia, ça ne peut pas arriver.
Voilà ce qui se passe. Et aujourd'hui,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On a Salvini qui
refuse l'accès à un bateau dans ses
ports. Ça fait beaucoup de bruit. Tout
le monde est là à dire "Oh Salvini, il
est méchant ! Salvini, c'est un sale
nationaliste et cetera."
Et puis pendant ce temps-là, ce qu'on ne
voit pas, c'est les nominations qui fait
au poste clés comme président de
l'Assemblée et cetera qui sont tous des
économistes et tous des économistes qui
peuvent pas voir l'euro en peinture,
ils sont pas eurosceptiques, ils sont
europhobes.
Et là, on peut se poser la question, on
se dit "Oh, est-ce qu'il agiterait pas
la main sur les migrants ? histoire de
nous faireourner
un petit coup d'arnaque
sur le l'euro, c'est une possibilité.
Sachez quand même que s'ils le font
euh c'est alors soit il le décide,
soit ça peut arriver aussi euh à l'insu
de leur plein gris, on va dire. Pourquoi
? Je vous rappelle qu'il y a 350
milliards de dettes pourries
en Italie. Quand je dis pourri, c'est
pas un peu pourri, c'est beaucoup
pourri.
Et que en face d'eux euh 350 milliards
petite petite précision, c'est 22 % du
PIB italien. C'est pas un tout petit une
petite somme comme ça sur lequel on peut
faire l'impasse. [grognement]
Or, je vous rappelle qu'ils ont en phase
d'eux des fonctionnaires non que j'adore
[raclement de gorge]
avec une ciatique à partir de 14h
systématiquement
et qui
ont un certain nombre de dogmes et donc
qui ne probablement qu' ne verront pas
le couvenir.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé au moment de
de des élections ? On a bien vu que la
BCE rentrait dans le jeu en essayant de
forcer et de peser sur le la formation
du gouvernement en achetant plus et donc
en laissant monter les taux italiens.
Les taux italiens, ils sont montés
jusqu'à 310 320.
Ils sont pas loin là d'ailleurs.
Et ils sont pas loin.
Euh pourquoi ? Bah parce que ce soir on
annonce le budget italien et que là on
va très probablement commencer à
s'envoyer des petits noms d'oiseau de
part et d'autre frontière
en en expliquant que ce budget est trop
déficitaire et que c'est pas bien.
Qu'est-ce qui peut se passer ? Il peut
se passer qu'il y ait une tension plus
forte sur les taux, qu'on se retrouve
avec des taux à 4 % et si jamais on se
retrouve avec des taux à 4 %, vu le
niveau de dette et vu le niveau de dette
pourri qu'il y a en Italie, là il y a un
énorme risque sur les banques.
[grognement] Qui dit énorme risque sur
les banques dit
risque systémique de contagion. Donc là,
la question qu'il faut se poser, donc là
on est en train de se projeter sur
l'année qui vient, c'est que finalement
est-ce que
l'Europe dans son ensemble à travers ses
autorités essentiellement monétaire va
gérer la situation italienne avec une
forme ou une dose de morale
ou de dogme ou d'idéologie ou on va dire
plutôt sur le sur la trajectoire
américaine avec un froid pragmatisme ?
Ce qu'on est en train de dire, c'est que
si l'Europe fait le choix à travers
notamment la Banque centrale européenne
de ne pas protéger une partie de ces
sortissant à savoir les Italiens d'une
hausse des taux d'intérêt qui correspond
directement à une attaque spéculative
contre les obligations italiennes. Si la
Banque centrale européenne ne se met pas
en face joue son rôle de premier
défenseur d'un des nôtres concrètement
ça générera des dommages collatéraux qui
seront difficilement gérables et là on
pourrait être dans une situation de
risque systémique de contagion et
forcément si les Italiens constatent que
lorsqu'ils sont en difficulté bah
l'Europe les défend pas on pourrait en
tout cas basculer dans une dimension où
bah il est légitime de s'en détacher.
Donc il y a un vrai sujet à regarder. Je
suis un peu plus optimiste que toi par
enfin moins jusqu'au 2e semestre 2019
parce que quand même depuis 5 6 ans on a
plus un français à la tête de la banque
centrale européenne.
[raclement de gorge] On a un italien qui
s'appelle Mario Dragui et qui a quand
même fait preuve d'un pragmatisme à
l'américaine depuis pas mal de temps. Et
donc on peut espérer en tout cas qu'il y
mette suffisamment peu de morale pour
comprendre qu'il n'aurait aucun intérêt
pour les pour les Européens de laisser
tomber l'Italie parce que la récession
italienne forcément aurait des effets de
contagion sur ses voisins. Et dans un
monde déjà tendu, alors vous avez
compris hein, tout à l'heure, on vous a
parlé du match finalement
États-Unis-Chine. Pour l'instant,
l'Europe compte les points parce qu'elle
a assez de problèmes en interne à gérer
pour justement s'imisser dans dans cette
discussion internationale. Et ce
problème là, c'est un c'est pas un
problème, c'est un fait. C'estd que le
choix des Italiens nous met face
finalement à
une vraie question. Est-ce que nous
sommes en capacité de gérer la zone euro
de manière froide et pragmatique ? Donc
à savoir défendre l'ensemble de ces
ressortissants à travers les taux
d'intérêt pour éviter que ceci ne monte
trop parce que ça met en difficulté tout
le monde ou pas ? Si la réponse est
négative, de manière évidente, l'Italie
ne supportera pas cela. En gros, les
ménages, les ménages italiens sont
incapables de supporter des taux qui
montent de 1,8 % à 10 ans. C'est comme
si vous en étez aujourd'hui pour acheter
votre maison allez 1,8 % et que
après-demain, vous pouvez plus vous
endetter à 1,8 % mais à 4 ou 4 et demi.
Vous comprenez très vite que vous allez
pas acheter le même prix, hein, que vous
allez pas consommer de la même manière,
que les entreprises vont pas investir de
la même manière. Alors déjà qu'en Italie
on a peu de potentiel, il est évident
que les agents privés italiens,
entreprises et ménages seraient dans
l'incapacité totale de supporter cette
hausse des taux. Et si la Banque
centrale européenne ne se met pas en
face euh je dirais pour les protéger, il
est probable que les Italiens réagissent
avec une décision plus brutale
finalement qu'un gouvernement hybride
qui n'a rien changé jusque-l et des
décisions beaucoup plus conséquentes
pour les autres. Donc la vraie question
c'est sommes-nous capables de voir
l'économie et la politique monétaire
avec la froideur et le pragmatisme
nécessaire que les autorités notamment
américaines dont les autorités
américaines font preuve déjà depuis une
dizaine d'années ? Question : tu en
penses quoi ?
Je
veis dire d'où vient ce ce subit accès
de souverainisme ?
Non alors je je je parle pas en fait de
la de la est-ce que c'est la bonne
solution ou pas la bonne solution ? Non
non, je parle pas de ça. Je te pose une
question précise.
La question j'ai répondd que tout à
l'heure qui taille nué le serpent le
mort qui creuse un trou il tombe. C'est
qu'aujourd'hui en fait on a les
conséquences en fait de simplement de
l'expression des populations qui
constatent l'inadéquation des modèles
tels qu'on les a conçus par le passé
profondément inégalitaire et qu'ils sont
devenus de plus en plus aujourd'hui avec
l'évolution de leur propre vie. Et
jusqu'à maintenant, d'ailleurs les les
Européens en général sont assez
légitimistes. Ils sont assez
légitimistes. On reverse difficilement
en fait la table du revers de main. Mais
concrètement face à l'incapacité
de nos autorités à véritablement
réinventer des modèles pour justement
palier en fait les déficits qu'on
constate depuis maintenant quelques
décennies et donc de construire des
modèles qui sont à nouveau adaptés à ce
que sont les gens. Et bien au début, ils
y croient et progressivement ils y
croient de moins en moins. Et d'ailleurs
souvisme ou pas ? Parce que tu as dit le
gouvernement hybride donc italien c'est
un mix des deux. C'est simplement un
vote qui traduit une chose, c'est la
frustration des populations quant à
l'incapacité des autorités telles
qu'elles ont géré nos modèles jusque-là
de les modifier pour répondre à leurs
besoins. Et donc ça peut aller d'un côté
comme de l'autre peu importe. Le sens du
vote, c'est un un vote euh d'élimination
des gens qui se proposent de reproduire
des modèles, voilà, qu'on a dont on a
hérité au cours des 40 dernières années.
Donc je dirais, je mettrai même pas cela
sur le plan du souvise ou pas. C'est en
fait c'est vraiment l'inadéquation de
l'offre politique actuelle en terme de
modèle puisqu'on a un seul modèle qu'on
nous propose plus de concentration, plus
de consolidation. Il n'a d'air, il n'y a
d'avenir en fait dans notre monde qu'à
travers les gros, les grandes
métropoles, les grandes entreprises. Il
faut plus qu'on ait des qu'on ait des
petites entreprises, on doit avoir que
des grosses entreprises. D'ailleurs, les
réformes au cours des derniers mois
tendent encore un peu plus à renforcer
ce mécanisme là. C'est déjà le mécanisme
à l'œuvre depuis 40 ans. Et clairement,
les populations aujourd'hui disent "Ce
n'est plus le modèle qu'on souhaite." Et
donc, on a vraiment une adéquation de la
manière dont on est piloté et du besoin
des gens. À la fin, on sait qu'il gagne
d'une manière ou d'une autre. Si les
autorités font pas de progressisme,
refont pas la loi 1901, refont pas la
loi 1905, recrée pas en fait un système
coopératif, je sais pas les solutions,
hein, recrée pas en fait une une manière
de répondre à ce besoin de moins de gros
et probablement un peu plus de petits.
S'ils sont pas capables de le faire
progressivement, les gens voteront pour
la rupture et après il y a plein de
manières de voter pour la rupture. Et on
constate déjà que finalement Donald
Trump c'est le premier pas, l'Italie
c'est le second pas, mais le sens des
votes partout dans les pays riches au
Japon parce Japonais sont un peu
spéciaux quand même. Voilà mais il un
peu entre eux mais c'est déjà le cas
partout donc c'est vraiment en fait les
conséquences de l'inadaptation d'un
modèle au regard de notre propre
transformation.
Donc j'ai pas répondu.
Non mais comme à ton d'habitude.
Je te remercie. [rires]
On finit sur la France. On en a déjà
parlé. Tu veux leur passe on a le temps.
Oui.
Allez, on prend [rires]
[raclement de gorge]
euh on va finir sur la France. Alors,
justement, on a on a euh eu un un
nouveau jeune président
euh on n' pas toujours compris ce qui
est raconté, mais on voit bien dans quel
sens il va.
Euh donc vers
net, euh vers plus d'Europe alors que
c'est pas le mouvement qu'on sche dans
la population. Euh et
il a l'air d'en faire une obsession.
Je me trompe ? Non
non non non. Je dirais que au moins
c'est assez clair. Il est vrai que la
vision qui est posée donc petit
personnel, je suis très macronier
macroni, je sais pas comment il faut le
dire. Vous l'avez compris. C'estàd que
lorsque l'environnement change, il est
évident qu'il faut changer. Donc cette
pulsion réformiste, il faut y souscrire.
Personne ne peut aujourd'hui au regard
de ce qu' ce qu'on vient de dire
simplement restons immobile et
reproduisons les pratiques d'entemps.
Elles sont et elles sont devenues
inadaptées. Donc ça, on peut souscrire
en fait au postulat de base. La
question, une fois qu'on est d'accord
là-dessus et je crois qu'on est tous à
peu près d'accord dans cette salle, la
question c'est pourquoi faire ? Et c'est
là où le il faut reprendre finalement la
démarche de la reconstruction d'un
modèle. Le préalable à la reconstruction
du modèle à partir du moment où on a
constaté que c'était nécessaire, c'est
la vision. La vision en fait qu'on a du
monde et du coup la place qu'on veut y
prendre. Et là il y a un vrai sujet, il
y a un beau sujet politique et à la
limite Emmanuel Macron a au moins en
fait l'avantage d'être clair dans cette
vision là. Donc pour lui cette vision du
monde elle passe à travers les groupes.
Pour exister dans ce monde-là, il faut
qu'on soit puissant. en gr et le levier
de la puissance ce sont les gros sont
les gros c'està dire que ce sont les
métropoles en général et ce sont des
très grosses entreprises au détriment
des petits. Et c'est très cohérent quand
vous regardez la les réformes qui sont
implémentées depuis un certain nombre
depuis le début d'année par exemple. Il
se trouve que mon cabinet est au cœur
d'un certain nombre de sujets de ce
type. C'est très clair. C'est très
clair. C'estd que l'objectif c'est la
consolidation. On supprime dans un
écosystème trop complexe avec trop de
petits et bien on va créer les
conditions pour que le petit se
rassemble. en tout cas où soit bouffé ou
meurt au profit des gros et c'est pareil
sur les territoires. Donc ça ce qui est
intéressant c'est que finalement on a un
jeune président qui utilise une vision
assez proche de celle du 20e siècle à
savoir la reproduction et la continuité
d'un modèle qui est déjà N depuis 3 à qu
décennies. Mais quand je dis le node,
c'est pas le NE tout seul, c'est le Note
partout. C'était celui des États-Unis,
c'était celui de l'Allemagne, c'est un
petit peu différent, mais celui de tous
les pays riches. Donc on a fait on a
tous fait la même chose et c'est là où
probablement il y a peut-être un virage
manqué mais c'est dommage. Mais après
laissons lui le le en gros le loisir de
de pouvoir évoluer. OK, attention, on
fait de la projection [rires]
mais c'est probablement une erreur
historiqueidée
de historique
de croire aujourd'hui que le besoin des
gens c'est plus de gros et au contraire
pas plus de petit. Et d'ailleurs, c'est
d'autant plus dommage que on a une autre
révolution. Tout à l'heure, on a parlé
de la révolution démographique qui
change la tat du gâteau à se partager de
manière structurelle. On passe en fait
d'un monde en expansion un monde plus
proche de la stagnation ou de la
stabilisation. C'est pas grave, c'est
comme ça. Il y a l'autre révolution qui
est la révolution technologique et
numérique. Et c'est là où c'est quand
même dommage avec finalement la
modernité qu'il a pu nous apporter qu'il
saisisse pas en fait de ce dossier. Pour
la première fois dans l'histoire,
lorsqu'on parle de décentralisation,
c'est très actuel. Vous avez vu le notre
premier ministre est intervenu ou
intervient donc
dans un colloque pour parler justement
de décentralisation. Pour la première
fois dans l'histoire, on a vraiment les
moyens de faire de la décentralisation.
On a vraiment les moyens en fait de se
rapprocher de la population à travers
des petites unités. Pour la première
fois dans l'histoire, on peut faire
vivre ensemble l'initiative locale
atomique tout en ayant une dimension
globale globale grâce à la mise en
relation que les technologies
permettent. Et au lieu de ça, on fait
quoi ? On fait les grandes régions. On
recrée en France des sous-états sous
l'état. C'est un non sens absolu.
L'avenir n'appartient pas au gros ou
n'appartient plus au gros. elle
appartient aux petits mis en réseau et
qui deviendront finalement des
concurrents des gros actuels. Et c'est
là où on aurait pu espérer que Emmanuel
Macron saisisse cette chance historique
de refaire la France peut-être la
lumière du monde comme tout à l'heure on
parlait du 19e donc le siècle des
lumières. On a cette occasion, on avait
cette occasion, on a encore cette
occasion-là de bien comprendre que
l'avenir n'appartient pas à la
reproduction d'un modèle qui est grosso
modo pyramidal, vertical et qui
finalement ne laisse d'espace que pour
le gros et que l'avenir appartient
probablement plus aux gens voilà qu'on
met ensemble, sur lesquels en fait qu'on
peut suffisamment motiver à travers
l'adhésion qu'il va avoir pour le projet
que vous allez leur proposer tout en
ayant une dimension globale grâce à la
mise en relation que la technologie
permet. Tout ce qu'on dit là, ça veut
dire que une des clés de notre modèle de
main, c'est réinventer le système
coopératif tel qu'on l'a fait au début
du 20e à travers nos banques, à travers
les coopératives agricoles qui ont été
des énormes succès et simplement en les
modernisant au regard des euh de la
technologie à disposition. Donc c'est
dommage, c'estd qu'à partir moment où on
est d'accord sur le nécessaire
changement aujourd'hui finalement les
projets qu'on voit finalement ne sont
que la reproduction de ce qui se passe
en un peu plus fort je dirais depuis 40
ans.
La deuxième chose, on vous en avait
parlé à la fin de la conférence l'année
dernière, c'est aussi mais ça ça se
rejoint, c'est l'hypers spécialisation
des pays. C'est-à-dire que vous avez des
pays aujourd'hui qui sont monomodèles.
Le Japon tout à l'export.
L'Allemagne qui exporte quoi ? Des
voitures.
Si je fais en très gros très gros mais
bon
ça exporte des voitures. Ça exporte un
peu de mécanique mais qui est lié à la
voiture. Donc ça fait quand même des
voitures. Et l'Italie c'est de la
mécanique de précision
c'est de l'hypers spécialisation.
Portugal par exemple qui euh dans les
années 60 avait 25 % euh de son PIB qui
était euh de l'agriculture
euh aujourd'hui c'est quatre
pas 25 c'est 4. Ça veut dire quoi ? Ça
veut dire que tout a été remplacé par du
tertiaire. Tertiaire. Alors, c'est bien
si vous voulez, ça marche tant que ça
marche. Et puis quand il y a un problème
et on l'avait vu par exemple au moment
du tsunami au Japon, je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez, vous aviez toutes les
chaînes de production de voiture dans le
monde qui étaient arrêtées. Pourquoi
elles étaient arrêtées ? Tout simplement
parce qu'il y a un petit composé
qui coûtait moins d'un dollar
à à l'achat.
et qui était fabriqué dans une usine qui
pas de bol était à côté de Fukushima.
Le monde entier s'arrête,
les voitures s'entassent sur les
parkings
mais il y en a pas une qui sort et qui
est finie. Et ça c'est gravissime. C'est
gravissime. Pourquoi ? parce que on a
des pays aujourd'hui qui n'ont aucun
relais
dans leur croissance, dans leur
développement
inter
parce que elles se sont spécialisées
et que aujourd'hui si jamais il y a un
pépin quelque part, si jamais il y a un
grand de sable et bien ces sociétés là
s'arrêtent.
Ce que tu dis finalement, c'est c'est
vraiment l'héritage de de ton métier, de
notre métier, celui finalement de dire
que la première gestion du risque, c'est
la diversification.
C'est vrai dans le monde financier,
c'est dans le monde patrimonial, c'est
aussi vrai dans le monde économique.
Parce que attention là aussi, c'est quel
je dirais l'apse de temps on prend comme
référence. L'hyperspécialisation, c'est
très efficace à un moment donné, mais il
ne faut pas nier le risque associé et
lorsque ça se retourne, comment vous
vous survivez ? Donc la question c'est
est-ce que la croissance que vous
arrivez à collecter grâce à cela,
n'allez-vous pas la rendre gérer dans
des proportions encore plus importantes
si jamais les règles du jeu changent ?
Et ce que tu dis c'est finalement
porteur d'espoir. Tout à l'heure, on a
dit quoi ? On a dit que la la deuxième
lame ou la 3è lame, le 3ème étage de la
fusée américaine, ça va être
probablement taper sur les grands
conglomérats, Apple ou autre. Donc je
sais pas si tu l'as sur toi, mais où est
ton téléphone ? La première chose, c'est
que la politique industrielle de
l'Europe et si l'Europe veut pas le
faire de la France, c'est aujourd'hui
s'organiser parce qu'on va vous dire
"Oui, mais imaginez si les Européens
dans ce mondeel, on va vivre sans iPhone
et toi tu as quoi ? Ass un téléphone
chinois
donc on va vivre sans téléphone mais ça
ne doit pas arriver.
Ça dans un monde qui devient tendu, on
ne peut plus l'accepter et l'Europe a
déjà été capable de le faire. Airbuch,
il y a tout un tas de réussites
industrielles et économiques qui nous
ont permis de construire des champions
qui nous rendent autonomes par rapport
aux autres. Et dans un monde qui se tend
pour des raisons structurelles, il est
dangereux de ne pas considérer cet
autonomie cette autonomie là comme le
premier levier de liberté donc dans le
monde de demain. Et qu'on me disent pas
qu'on a pas d'argent pour financer en
fait ces leaders qui pourra être des
concurrents. Limite on s'en fout de la
concurrence. L'objectif c'est pas d'être
concurrent de Google ou de concurrent
d'Apple. Ça va être simplement que notre
territoire et nos ressortissants
puissent continuer de vivre si jamais
les règle du chang et empêche de
consommer comme par le passé. Et qu'on
ne nous disent pas qu'on a pas d'argent,
on a investi entre 1500 et 2000
milliards d'euros donc sous forme de
quantitative easing, c'est-à-dire la
banque centrale européenne est descendue
dans la cave à imprimé 1 milliard 1500 à
2000 milliards d'euros depuis depuis
combien ? depuis 2014 pour racheter des
obligations d'état, on peut très bien
faire une ligne de crédit qui permet
d'avoir les fonds à des à des
entreprises européennes ou française
pour fabriquer un équivalent alors
peut-être moins joli avec un moins beau
logo mais un équivalent tout de même un
équivalent à Google équivalent à Amazon.
Dans ce monde là, en fait, on peut et on
doit considérer au niveau au niveau
européen un minima d'avoir une solution
de substitution à aujourd'hui des
fournisseurs qui infinés ne sont pas
sous notre coupe, peuvent prendre des
décisions brutales du jour au lendemain
contre lesquelles vous n'aurez aucun
moyen de lutter. Donc ça aussi c'est un
élément sur lequel il faut vraiment
travailler, c'est que on pose des
diagnostics assez sévères, je vous
concède, mais tout est possible, on peut
tout réinventer. Le seul danger, ça
serait simplement imaginer que les
solutions du passé puissent être à
nouveau la solution. Elles ont montré
leur inefficacité et là, il faut faire
preuve d'innovation et bien comprendre
que l'autonomie finalement de nos
territoires, après la question de
l'échelle à savoir est-ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est l'Auverne, est-ce que
c'est la France, est-ce que c'est
l'Europe, c'est un choix politique ?
choix qui vous voilà qui vous
appartient. Mais en tout cas, considérer
que la simple reproduction d'un modèle
hérité du passé sera la solution. Ça
marchera pas.
On s'arrête là, on leur donne la parole
très rapidement. On donne la parole
directement. Très bien. Allez,
[raclement de gorge] merci beaucoup pour
votre attention et voilà,
on est passé on va passer de l'économie
[applaudissements] à la géopolitique.
Comment on fait ? Vous démarrez.
Bravo ! Super hein ? Merci.
Super conférence.
Ouais.
Ben, je vais me mettre au milieu aussi.
Bonsoir à tous.
On je crois qu'on va faire un on va
faire un peu différemment parce que
d'abord moi je suis tout seul donc on va
faire quand même un dialogue. Donc je
vais demander à un ami qui est là de
pouvoir poser relancer ou poser des
questions puis ça me permettra de
démarrer, de répondre hein pour essayer
de continuer euh dans un domaine un peu
différent mais aussi peut-être aussi un
peu dans ce domaine là aussi. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Oui, sachant qu'en attendant qu'il règle
son téléphone son son micro, euh moi ce
que je voudrais dire si d'abord je
partage à 80 98 % ce que j'ai entendu.
Donc si vous voulez euh sur ça avec
juste un point que je voudrais quand
même mentionner mais mais qui d'ailleurs
on va je pense qu'ils seront d'accord,
c'est que il faut surtout pas oublier
que le 21e siècle nous sommes rentrés
dans l'erreur du numérique et que le
numérique amène à l'individualisation
hein. Le numérique tue le groupe puisque
chacun est capable d'avoir les
informations et va les avoir de plus en
plus, les traiter et les utiliser.
C'est pour ça que d'ailleurs je rejoins
par contre dans cette voie là ce qui a
été dit tout à l'heure à savoir que
penser que l'avenir est réservé au gros
et tout mettre sur les gros, c'est aller
exactement en sens contraire par rapport
à ce qui va se passer avec toutes les
conséquences que ça peut avoir.
Alain Julillet, bonsoir.
Bonsoir. Ouais,
je vous interview pour la chaîne YouTube
Securer Viiew en partenariat avec
l'école de guerre.
Euh est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler
succintement qui vous êtes pour nos
internautes et ceux de de la B ? Moi,
c'est ça a été dit tout à l'heure hein.
Moi, j'ai commencé ma carrière comme
militaire
euh comme officier aussi dans les unités
parachutistes puis au service action.
Ensuite, j'ai quitté l'armée, je suis
rentré dans les entreprises à
l'international et puis j'ai fait pas
mal de choses et puis j'ai terminé en
dirigeant un certain nombre
d'entreprises française et étrangère
jusqu'au moment où l'État m'a redemandé
de venir travailler pour lui comme
directeur du renseignement à la DGSE,
puis ensuite comme patron de
l'intelligence économique pendant pas
mal d'années et puis maintenant ben je
continue à faire pas mal de choses un
peu partout en France à l'étranger. Et
là, vous voyez par exle, j'arrive de
Washington, on avait une réunion hier
avec enfin depuis 48 he avec des vins
français 20 américain sur justement les
problèmes de cybersécurité et sur
comment on va s'y prendre pour faire
face non seulement au problème de
cybersécurité mais derrière à toute
cette politique de fake news qui se
développe dans tous les coins du monde
mais qui devient de plus en plus
difficile à séparer de la réalité.
Alors ce soir le thème c'est l'état du
monde. Vous parlez de fake news.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez pu aborder avec
vos collègues américain ? Plus en
détail. Est-ce que vous avez entendu
parler du rapport français fait par le
CAPS ?
Oui.
Concernant la propagande russe.
Tout à fait. Ah ben d'ailleurs, on
l'avait hein, on avait amené le rapport
hein. Donc il est il est fort bien fait.
Ce qui est intéressant sur le sur le
point de les fake news aux États-Unis,
c'est que ils sont aujourd'hui
absolument obsédés par les démocrates,
il faut préciser, les démocrates
américains sont obsédés parce qu'ils ont
perdu la bataille de l'élection
présidentielle et ils sont convaincus
que c'est à cause de fausses nouvelles
qu'on est donné par les Russes et donc
les fameuses fake news. Et là, je crois
qu'il faut tout de suite là aussi, il
faut ramener la les il faut mettre les
pieds dans la réalité. La réalité c'est
que quel est là on a toutes les
sondages, les mesures ont été faites
là-dessus. Quelle est l'information
divulguée par les Russes qui a qui a
plombé
véritablement la candidature d'Hillary
Clinton ? C'est la publication des
échanges mail
entre et Twitter, Twitter et Facebook
entre Hillary Clinton et son directeur
de campagne.
Donc c'est ce sont des faits réels
mais des faits réels qui ne devaient pas
être publiés parce que dans ses faits
réels, elle dit ce qu'elle pense qui n'a
rien à voir avec ce qu'elle dit durant
la campagne.
Et c'est ça qui a posé le problème. Ce
qui fait qu'ils en veulent la mort aux
Russes en disant "Les Russes ont envoyé
des fake news, mais en réalité les
Russes, ils ont fait de l'interception."
C'est vrai, mais ils ont piqué des
fichiers mais ils n'ont fait que
reproduire la vérité. Et alors là,
est-ce que c'est une fake news ou pas ?
Et j'en profite pour vous dire ça parce
que lorsqu'on a parlé en France d'une
loi sur les fake news, vous savez hein,
lorsqu'on a parlé en France d'une loi
sur les fake news, on a dit "Ah, c'est
épouvantable, les fake tout." Non, il
faut savoir ce que c'est qu'une fake
news. Les vraies fake news, les bonnes
aujourd'hui, c'est une vérité qu'on ne
doit pas savoir et qu'on vous balance en
pleine figure.
Celle-là, elle est imparable
et pourtant, on le voit bien, il y a une
tendance générale à le faire quand on
peut, bien entendu, quand on a les
moyens. Alors, il y a une deuxiè
deuxième type de fake news, c'est ce qui
se passe dans les opérations qui peuvent
être menées au niveau politique ou au
niveau militaire, par exemple. au niveau
Oui. Quand on voit par exle quand on va
faire des opérations et où on fait une
opération et on a besoin de mettre un
accompagnement. Je vous rappelle le plus
beau beaucoup quand même de fake news,
ça été quand même la guerre en Irak, la
première guerre d'Irak
où les Américains ont balancé au monde
entier que même à la deuxième guerre
d'Irak. D'ailleurs, les Américains ont
balancé au monde entier que Saddam
Hussein était en train de faire la bombe
atomique
et que le monde entier à part nous,
heureusement, il y a quand même eu un
pays qui a résisté, c'est normal, c'est
Astérix. Mais à part nous, les autres,
la plupart des pays du monde, il ont cru
et même encore aujourd'hui. Moi, j'ai vu
encore dans aux États-Unis, dans le dans
la zone des États-Unis, l'Amérique
profonde qui soutient Trump actuellement
alors à 90 %.
Et bien quand vous leur parlez de la
gare d'Irak, il disent "On a bien fait,
il allait avoir la bombe atomique et il
fallait arrêter ça aujourd'hui encore."
Alors que tout le monde sait que c'est
une ça a été une invention, une fake
news lancée par les Américains pour
faire passer l'idée d'une guerre juste
alors que ce n'était pas une guerre
juste du tout puisque c'était une guerre
pétrolière.
Je vous je vous coupe. C'était les
Russes ou Wikileak pour les fuites du
DNC ?
Ah, les Russes ? Pour Wikileak,
c'était Wikileak ou les Russes pour la
fuite concernant la campagne de
d'Hillary Clinton ?
Euh non, ça a été les Russes qui ont
balancé le plus, hein, qui ont balancé.
Alors Wikileag en a rajouté mais comme
maintenant Wikileag est très suspecté
d'avoir des relations alors certains
vous diront avec les Chinois, d'autres
avec les Russes, enfin pas eu tout le
monde hein, c'est là c'est mais en
réalité c'est bel et bien il y a eu
c'est l'institut de dirait de FN enfin
l'institut qui est à Saint-Pétersbourg
hein qui est un institut spécialisé et
qui a qui a qui a sorti l'information
et et autre question vous vous êtes allé
à Washington avec le rapport du CAPS
oui
plus de 200 page. Euh, on fait
aucunement mention de cette fake news de
la guerre en Irak et de la propagande de
guerre sur le territoire français.
Oui, mais c'est vrai c'est vrai que dans
mais vous savez sur les flectus, il y a
tellement de choses à dire
hein. Regarde regardez la guerre en
Syrie aujourd'hui. La guerre en Syrie,
c'est un il y a il faut il faudrait
écrire les fake news et la guerre en
Syrie.
Quand on voit l'exploitation qui est
faite par des gens qui sont très bons de
tous les côtés pour être honnête,
quand on voit l'exploitation qui est
faite pour justement faire pousser les
lecteurs ou les auditeurs ou les
spectateurs dans un sens ou dans un
autre, on voit bien que en définitive
les gens se font manipuler mais
pratiquement inconsciemment. Là, il y en
il y a dans l'auditoire, il y a pas mal
de militaires. Moi, j'aimerais qu'on
m'explique la différence
au niveau de l'horreur
entre balancer une caisse explosive
depuis un hélicoptère à 100 m de haut
ou tirer depuis un avion qui était à
5000 m ou à 10000 m, une bombe qui fait
le même poids sur le même objectif.
Expliquez-moi pourquoi l'un est
inacceptable
selon les médias et l'autre est normal.
On voit bien que c'est nous sommes dans
une manipulation de l'information. On
joue sur l'émotionnel et on va vous
présenter quelque chose qui après tout
dans le cadre de la guerre banale, on va
le présenter comme une simple une
horreur.
Regardez ce qui se passe avec les avec
le chimique. C'est très intéressant ce
qui se passe avec le chimique. Quand les
quand les
les Syriens et les Russes ont décidé de
avec les Iraniens d'essayer de régler le
problème d'Hiblide de la zone d'Ibli qui
est la dernière grande zone tenue par
les rebelles incluant les les les
jihadistes et les autres. Bon, qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé ? Et bien,
immédiatement, une fois que les les
Syriens et les Russes ont annoncé qu'ils
allaient attaquer, enfin du moins, ils
allaient essayer de régler le problème
d'Hiblide, les Américains tout de suite
ont dit "Attention, s'il y a attaque
chimique, on va intervenir."
Et aujourd'hui, les Russes sont en train
de sortir depuis 3 jours des
informations pour montrer
comment effectivement il y a des groupes
qui sont en train de préparer des
informations pour faire croire à une
attaque chimique parce que c'est devenu
maintenant un enjeu stratégique
puisqu'on sait très bien que une attaque
chimique çaifie tout le monde avec
raison et c'est inacceptable.
En plus les lois, il y a quand même des
heureusement des lois qu'il faut
respecter. Donc c'est inacceptable. Mais
le problème c'est que la réalité de
l'attaque chimique elle mais il faut
être sûr qu'elle est vraie ou pas. Or on
sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui autant
dans une première partie de la guerre ça
a été utilisé de manière absolument
scandaleuse par les par Bachar Alassad.
Ça a été utilisé dans une deuxième
partie de la guerre par les Ges Daesh
avec des stocks [raclement de gorge]
qu'ils avaient saisis dans les entrepôts
de Bachar. Mais aujourd'hui, on a des
sérieux doutes quand on regarde le
dossier à fond sur ce qui s'est vraiment
passé les dernières fois. Regardez la
commission de l'ONU qui a fait celle de
la H. C'est les commissions qui ont été
étudiées ce qui s'est passé sur le
dernier bombardement chimique en Syrie.
Ils ont rien trouvé.
Ça pose problème quand même.
Et je vous et je vous donc on est donc
c'est ce que je veux vous montrer par
là, c'est moi je vous dis pas c'est
bien, c'est mal, il y a les bien, il y a
les gentils, il y a les méchants. Ce que
je veux dire c'est que nous sommes dans
un monde dans lequel les fake news
deviennent un élément stratégique,
des opérations d'influence si vous
voulez qui vont servir d'un côté ou de
l'autre. Et donc s'il y en a un qui en
balance une, l'autre va monter un
contrefeu.
Donc on est dans et c'est et là ça fait
partie à ce de la guerre hybride, ce
qu'on appelle la guerre hybride.
Des préconisations pour euh combattre
les fake news dans l'esprit euh critique
de nos populations.
[grognement]
C'est très difficile.
Je crois que c'est très difficile parce
que pour pouvoir parce qu'on on a du mal
à comprendre d'abord ce qui se passe, il
faut du temps pour décoder ce qui se
passe et les médias eux ont cette
capacité de réagir dans l'instant et de
surmédiatiser dans l'instant hein. Si
quelque chose se passe quelque part, des
des des télévisions d'information vont
vous sortir dans les 10 minutes qui
suivent une quantité d'informations
là-dessus qui vont être liées par des
experts, plus ou moins experts, mais on
les aura trouvé pour qu'ils puissent
parler. hein. Et on va et on va
continuer à faire monter un espèce de
1000 feuilles médiatique hein et dans
lequel en définitive
très peu de gens ont vérifié l'origine
de l'information parce que c'est ça le
fond du problème. Aujourd'hui,
l'information circule extrêmement vite
par la médiatisation partout dans tous
les domaines. On peut prendre dans
n'importe quel domaine pareil. Ça va
très très vite. Et là, le problème c'est
tout le monde en parle, tout le monde
trouve des informations sur internet ou
ailleurs, mais en définitive personne ne
vérifie ce qu'on a raconté au début,
l'origine du fait. par et pour une
raison très simple, c'est que pour
vérifier l'origine, il faut plusieurs
jours ou plusieurs semaines et que le
média, il a besoin de quelque chose qui
va montrer dans l'heure dans la minute
ou dans l'heure
3 jours après, c'est oublié par autre
chose.
Parce que c'est ça la monde actuel,
hein. On vous on vous annonce une
horreur et puis 3 jours après, vous
l'avez oublié parce qu'il y en a une
autre.
Est-ce qu'on peut parler du
réchauffement climatique et des
implications sur le livre blanc de la
défense française ?
Ah oui, ça c'est
Ah ben le réchauffement climatique
d'abord ça, il y a une conséquence.
Nous, bon, on parle bien sûr, on dit ça
va changer les climats chez nous un
petit peu, ça va réchauffer, il y aura
un peu plus d'eau, un peu moins d'eau.
Bon, mais sur le plan économique déjà,
il y a quand même quelque chose qui est
qu'on voit qui est extrêmement
important, c'est que le réchauffement
climatique est dans les zones Arctiques
et Antarctiques est en train
effectivement de d'enlever une bonne
partie des glaces. Et en ce qui concerne
la Sibérie en particulier, toute la zone
sibérienne hein, le permafros qui était
donc la terre qui était en permanence
gelée, hein, parce que c'était ça la
caractéristique de ce pays. La terre
était gelée, il y avait juste une toute
petite tranche de terre qui ne l'était
pas et sur lequel les gens essayaient de
vivre en faisant un peu de culture. Et
bien on va se retrouver maintenant et
c'est ça commence on se retrouve avec
cette cette terre qui devient dégelée
sur plusieurs mètres et à partir de ce
moment-là on rentre dans un dans une
autre formule. C'est-à-dire que on peut
l'exploiter différemment bien entendu
hein. On va voir que par exemple dans
les on parlait tout à l'heure des
terrares mais on va voir qu'au niveau au
niveau des mines par exemple et des
minerais et bien tout l'Arctique et
l'Antarctique représentent une richesse
potentielle considérable.
Alors, je sais que les écologistes
disent il faut préserver l'Arctique et
l'Antarctique. Moi, je je suis d'accord,
ils ont raison sur le fond, mais je
crois pas une seconde qu'on pourra
résister à la pression des pays qui vont
vouloir chacun exploiter les zones qui
sont les leurs parce que ça représente
des richesses considérables pour le
futur. Et oui, on parlait des terrares
par exemple, les terrares, les Chinois
contrôlent actuellement le marché des
terrars pour la plus grande partie. Ils
ont ils ont développé une stratégie pour
ça. Il est on sait déjà que dans
l'Arctique en particulier, il y a des
zones sur lesquelles il y a des zones de
minerais dans lesquelles on peut trouver
des des terrars en grande quantité.
Alors vous me direz terrar ça veut dire
aussi pollution exceptionnelle. Il faut
le savoir pour les traiter pour obtenir
les terrars il y a une un niveau de
pollution terrible. Donc ça veut dire
que dans ces zones vierges, on va se
retrouver avec une pollution maximale.
Ça va poser d'autres problèmes
sur sur les flux migratoires, sur le
la masse de peuples qui sont mis sur les
routes par le réchauffement climatique
et aussi par les guerres que ça
entraîne.
Est-ce que ça représente un risque pour
l'Europe ?
Je crois qu'il faut sur les sur les
risques migratoires, il faut il faut
ramener tout le monde à la réalité. Et
d'abord les phénomènes migratoires, ils
ont existé depuis toujours. Faut pas
oublier que la France s'est faite par le
passage successif dehors de Mir deord
hein, venu de Mongolie et d'ailleurs
hein. Les Visigo, ils étaient pas du
centre de la France. Les Gu, ils étaient
pas du centre de la France. les gars qui
sont venus qui sont les les hommes
d'Atila les un ils sont pas et ils sont
tous passés et ils ont laissé des gens
ils ont laissé des des morceaux de leur
leurs tribus de leurs bandes qui sont
installées. Donc les F migratoire il a
toujours existé. Le deuxième élément,
c'est que depuis toujours, on a des
phénomènes migratoires amplifiés quand
il y a des guerres normales, quand il y
a des conditions climatiques qui
deviennent insupportables, les gens
partent parce qu'ils ont ils ont pas de
quoi vivre hein, ils ont pas de bon ça
c'est c'est les deux événements
classiques. Et puis le troisième c'est
parce que quand les gens se disent que
eux chez eux ils ont aucun espoir de
s'en sortir alors qu'ailleurs c'est
attirant. Mais il faudrait pas croire
parce que là c'est une présomption je
dirais coloniale, excusez-moi du terme,
il faut pas croire que l'obsession p des
africains, c'est de venir en Europe
parce que ça c'est une absurdité totale.
La population, les les migrants qui
viennent qui viennent vers l'Europe ne
représentent pas plus de 10 % de la
totalité des migrants en Afrique.
Parce qu'en Afrique, les gars, avant
d'aller en Europe, ils vont dans les
pays riches d'Afrique.
C'estàd qu'il partent des pays pauvres,
ils vont dans les pays riches. Vous avez
par exemple, pour un exemple, les gars
du Mali, ben ils vont soit vers le
Sénégal, soit vers la Guinée, soit vers
la Côte d'Ivoire. Les gars du Burkina
Faso, ils vont sur la Côte d'Ivoire. Et
c'est tellement vrai que quand monsieur,
le président de la Côte d'Ivoire, a pris
le pouvoir, il l'a pris avec grâce au
votes des population immigré venue du
Burkina Fasso parce qu'il ne passait pas
avec les voix des locaux
et là ça nous choque pas.
Oui. Alors que pourtant c'est une
réalité et c'est partout pareil hein
parce que si on on aurait pu parler de
l'Asie avec la zone du delta du Mekong,
on pourrait parler de l'Amérique du Sud,
c'est partout pareil. Les phénomènes
migratoires se font dans tous les sens.
Alors ce qui se passe chez nous, c'est
que il y a eu effectivement d'abord il y
a eu effectivement une vague très
importante du fait des conflits
Afghanistan, Syrie et autres. Ça c'est
clair. Du fait aussi que il y a eu alors
en ce qui concerne l'Afrique, il y a eu
une véritable promotion de la migration
vers le nord par des organisations
criminelles. Parce que ça, on en parle
pas non plus. C'est c'est dommage mais
les mêmes routes qui servent aux
migrants en Afrique servent également
pour tous les grands trafics,
c'est-à-dire les trafics de cigarettes,
les trafics d'armes, les trafics de
drogues, les trafics de produits
pharmaceutiques
et vous retrouvez exactement les mêmes
les mêmes étapes, les mêmes routes dans
tous les cas de figure. Et les pauvres
migrants qui prennent ces routes là
parce que c'est les plus ça paraît la
plus les plus faciles se font
littéralement
esclavagés esclavagiser pardon hein
pendant sur la route à chaque étape.
C'est un véritable parcours du
combattant. Bon jusqu'au moment où ils
arrivent en Méditerranée hein et où là
il se trouvent avec d'autres problèmes
puisqu'il y a d'une part les gens qui
sont sur les côtes qui les exploitent.
Ça, on le sait maintenant très bien. Il
y a les passeurs qui les exploitent
aussi parce que les gens qui les font
passer de l'autre côté, c'est pas
gratuit, hein. Et puis ensuite, il y a
les réactions dans les pays européens
qui sont très fortes parce queon sait
bien que dans tout pays, dans tous les
pays du monde, c'est pareil et tous les
sociologues l'ont démontré, dès qu'on
atteint un certain seuil de population
extérieure, il y a des réactions de la
population locale. Ça c'est pas une
question de de politique ou de
philosophie. Tous les sociologues l'ont
étudié, c'est connu mais ça fait depuis
depuis très longtemps.
Si si on parlait un peu de la Chine,
vous avez quelques mot pour nous ?
Oui. Ben la Chine, j'ai entendu beaucoup
d'intérêt ce qui était dit sur la Chine
tout à l'heure. Euh moi [grognement] je
pense que il y a par rapport à ce qu'on
vous a dit sur j'ajouterai une petite
chose à ce moment-là. Moi c'est c'est
que les Chinois,
ils ont d'abord ils ont parfaitement
compris comment était l'Amérique
et en définitive je pense qu' ils
comprennent mieux Trump que nous tous.
Ça c'est clair.
Les Chinois qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ?
Ils ont fait une analyse, je vous parle
pas moi des trois bons en avant he de
Tscia Oping avec toutes les évolutions,
les 40 ans durant lesquels ils sont
restés sur la même stratégie, ce qui
explique pourquoi ils en sont là
maintenant. Mais ce qui est intéressant,
c'est pas ça. Ce qui est intéressant,
c'est de de voir la conception chinoise
du futur. Pour les Chinois, ils ont été
le plus grand pays du monde jusqu'au
moment où les anglais ont voulu leur
mettre de l'opium, ont imposé l'opium,
la consommation d'opium aux gens de chez
eux. Faut pas l'oublier. C'est les
Anglais qui l'ont introduit pil en se
battant hein contre les Chinois. et ce
qui a mis en l'air l'Empire chinois don
on y a contribué après les Français
aussi hein. Mais bon,
ils ont jamais oublié qu'ils étaient
jusqu dans les années 1700 et quelques
les plus puissants au monde et ils
disent on va y revenir.
Ça c'est très clair. Et comment ils ont
fait l'analyse suivante. Ils ont dit
"Nous, je parle pas de la partie je
dirais industrielle ça a été évoqué,
c'est pas ça." Moi ce que je pour
montrer la mentalité
au point de vue militaire.
En 1998,
il y a un livre qui s'appelle La guerre
sans limite qui a été écrit par deux
colonels chinois qui est essentiel pour
comprendre la stratégie chinoise et qui
vous éclaire sur beaucoup de choses.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ? Ils disent
"Jamais nous ne pourrons être aussi
forts que les États-Unis parce qu'ils
investissent un budget qui est colossal
par rapport au nôtre." Je vous rappelle
que cette année, on est passé de 610
milliards à 700 milliards de dollars aux
États-Unis. Ils sont à 210 en Chine,
trois fois un peu plus un peu plus de
trois fois moins. Bon, qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé ? Les Chinois, les les deux
colonels ont dit "Nous, on peut pas
lutter contre ça. On pourra pas avoir
autant d'avions, de sous-marins, de
porte-avion que les Américains. Donc,
comment peut-on faire pour les
neutraliser ou les gagner ?" Et dans ce
livre, il y a une phrase qui est très
enfin une phrase un chapitre entier qui
est très intéressant où ils disent "Dans
le fond, on prend la première ou la 2è
flotte américaine.
Ils sont plus puissants que tout ce
qu'il y a eu pendant la 2e guerre
mondiale.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe s'il y a plus de
liaison radio ou autre
les sous-marins, les destroyeurs, le
porte-avion, les avions et ainsi de
suite ? Et bien sûr tous les missiles et
tout ça et ben s'il y a plus de liaison,
ils peuvent être la plus puissante
flotte du monde. Ils ont perdu et ils
ont dit il faut donc qu'on s'attaque
nous à ces problèmes là. priorité à ça.
D'où par exemple le développement dans
le quantique. Une des raisons du
développement, il sa qu' sont plus en
avance que les autres dans le quantique.
Ils ont lancé un satellite qui utilise
partiellement hein des techniques
quantiques. C'est le premier hein. Et
ben on Et bien là c'est parce qu'ils ont
ils ont compris qu'il y avait quelque
chose à faire.
Un autre exemple qu'on peut prendre
parce que c'est toujours la même logique
si vous voulez hein, c'est récemment
quand vous regardez l'évolution actuelle
dans dans la cybersécurité
et la cyber tout court. Bon, on est tous
on en a parlé tout à l'heure, vous en
entendu parler tout à l'heure. Bon, tout
le monde est en train de se préoccuper
du numérique avec les algorithmes big
data.
OK. Et effectivement, les gars femmes,
hein, les les Américains, les groupes
américains surinvestissent dans cette
partie-là.
Alors maintenant, regardez regardez ce
qui se passe au niveau de l'intelligence
artificielle qui est l'étape suivante
parce que l'intelligence artificielle ça
vient après le traitement du big data et
de l'algorithme. Et bien les Européens
investissent 1 milliard 8
l'équivalent 1 milliard 8 de dollars
dans les pardon les Européens. Les
Américains investissent 11 milliards,
les Chinois sont estimés entre 20 et 40
milliards de dollars d'investissement
sur l'intelligence artificielle.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'ils disent, "Ils
seront peut-être bons dans l'étape
actuelle, mais nous on aura dépassé
l'étape actuelle. On les attend à
l'étape du dessus."
Je me souviens, c'était il y a qui il y
a très longtemps de ça, le patron de ce
le patron de Sunny à Kom Morita qui a
inventé le Walkman. Boman, c'est ce qui
a lancé tout derrière hein, le
maintenant tout ce qu'on a hein, les
iPhone, les smartphones, les tablettes,
tout cit venu de là. Et quand Morita, on
lui avait posé la question un à une
convention entre le reste industriel de
beaucoup de pays du monde, on lui avait
dit "Pourquoi vous avez inventé ce trucl
qui marche pas ? C'est nor, c'est
moderne mais ça marche pas." Et il a eu
cette réponse très simple. il a dit
"Attendez, vous êtes bien des
occidentaux,
vous regardez aujourd'hui. Moi, toutes
les études que j'ai fait faire montrent
que dans des 10 à 15 ans qui viennent,
tout le monde aura besoin de ce type
d'outil. Et au fur et à mesure où ils
vont avoir besoin de ce type d'outil,
ils viendront vers moi, je vais gagner
sans combat chez Rasunzo, hein, je vais
gagner sans combat la bataille du futur.
Et c'est vrai, et c'est vrai que pendant
un certain nombre d'années, les Japonais
ont dominé complètement cette partie des
cette partie technique. Ben, on est
exactement dans cette philosophie là.
Je vous je vous renvoie sur la Russie.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire sur la Russie
en ce moment ?
à la Russie. Je pense que c'est c'est
très intéressant ce qui se passe parce
que là aussi les Russes ils ont c'est on
nous raconte là aussi c'est des fake
news hein parce que quand on regarde on
nous dit la Russie l'ennemi enfin moi je
on parlait pas que les Américains hier
euh quand ils vous disent la Russie
c'est l'ennemi. On lui attendait 700
milliards d'un côté d'investissement
militaire de l'autre 65 milliards de qui
on se fout. Est-ce que vous pensez que
celui qui est 10 fois plus petit que
l'autre a la moindre chance de gagner
dans le long terme ? Donc il faut
ramener les choses à la réalité.
Seulement là aussi. Ils ont fait un peu
comme les comme les comme les Chinois.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait les Russes ?
Ils ont dit "On peut pas se battre
partout."
Ils ont abandonné la spécialisation que
vous évoquez tout à l'heure, ils ont
abandonné un certain nombre de domaines
qui les intéressent. Si on dit non, on
va pas se développer là-dessus parce que
c'est pas c'est pas des domaines dans
lequels on peut vraiment devenir leader.
Et par contre, ils ont développé juste
certains aspects qui leur permet là
d'être très performant. Regardez ce qui
regardez les S400, les missiles S400.
Bon, jusqu'à nouvel ordre, on sait on
sait pas comment faire pour les
neutraliser.
[raclement de gorge]
Ils ont donc trouvé un truc.
Il y a eu il y a il y a quelques mois
quel Oui. Quelques mois d'après ce qu'il
se dit, moi je suis pas mais après ce
que dit ce qui dit c'est dit dans les
journaux américains un navire de navire
américain en Méditerranée a vu débarquer
deux a vu arriver deux sous-coil qui
n'avaient pas été repérés c'est qu'ils
avaient atteint une furtivité absolue.
Là encore il y a des trucs
quand vous voyez les missiles de
croisière eux ils en sont au missile
hypersonique. Nous on sait pas faire on
sait pas répondre. Donc parce que nos
engins de défense contre des missiles de
croisière, nos missiles de défense ne
sont pas prêts à à tirer à traiter pour
le moment en tout cas des missiles
hypersoniques. Donc on voit bien que
dans chaque domaine, ils ont mis en
place quelques techniques particulières
sur lesquelles ils sont très en avance
par rapport aux autres.
[grognement]
Et à partir de ce moment-là,
et bien ils vont ils ont c'est là-dessus
qu'ils vont ils sont ils sont pas très
bons les Russes hein. Les troupes russes
sont pas formidables. Point de là, il
faut pas faut pas croire hein. Mais par
contre, ils ont ils se sont créés
quelques points forts et ils vont
exploiter ces points forts. À côté de
ça, c'est vrai qu'il y a une continuité.
Bon la Poutine, on peut aimer ou pas
aimer Poutine, mais il y a deux Moi, je
crois qu'il y a toujours deux chiffres
qu'il faut il ne faut jamais enfin il y
a un chiffre qu'il faut jamais oublier
quand on parle de Poutine aujourd'hui,
c'est que quand les Russes ont connu la
libération démocratique à la chute de
Gorbatchov,
leur pouvoir d'achat s'est effondré de
plus de 50 % et le pays est tombé entre
les mains des voyou.
Les Russes viennent de retrouver le
pouvoir d'achat qu'ils avaient à
l'époque communiste. La dernière année
de l'époque communiste. Ils l'ont
retrouvé il y a 2 ans.
Tout ce temps qui s'est passé, ils ont
tiré la langue parce qu'il fallait
essayer de remonter. Pour ça que la
vision de la démocratie par le peuple
russe est pas exactement la même que la
nôtre, hein. Quand vous discutez avec
eux, c'est pas la même chose. Il faut se
méfier d'ailleurs des interprétations.
Et Poutine est pour tous ces gens-là
celui qui a permis à la Russie de
revenir. Et quand il fait des opérations
fortes comme il a fait comme en
particulier comme il fait la Syrie, mais
il a fait la Crimée ou d'autres pour les
Russes, il y a un sentiment d'orgueil
national qui fait qu'ils se sentent très
fiers parce qu'ils disent "On est en
train de retrouver
un certain poids au niveau mondial, même
si ce poids, ils savent très bien, ils
sont pas fous, n'est qu'un poids
relativement réduit mais il n'empêche
qu'ils ont retrouvé, si vous voulez, ils
ils ne sont plus humiliés alors que
c'est un peuple qui est pourtant un
peuple le qui n'aime pas ça, les slaves,
ils aiment pas ça, mais qui a été
humilié pendant des années et ça on l'a
pas forcément compris. Alors moi
j'ajouterai une chose, ça c'est un
commentaire personnel, c'est je pense
que Poutine dans les années 20002
hein, au départ Poutine voulait
s'associer aux Européens.
On n pas voulu le faire pour d'autres
pour des raisons politiques et on va le
payer très cher parce que si c'était
associé à nous, ça permettait de faire
un blog qui était homogène par rapport
aux Américains et par rapport aux
Chinois. Alors que là, il est en train
de s'associer aux Chinois parce qu'il a
pas d'autres choix, même s'il sait que
la Sibérie est en train de se faire
renvahir par des millions de migrants
chinois et qui va perdre la Sibérie dans
les 20 ans. Si ça continue comme ça,
parce que ça sera totalement cisé et à
ce moment-là et vu l'éloignement, cette
partie de la Russie qui est la partie
riche hein, c'est là où il y a toutes
les mines et les réserves les réserves
énergétiques risquent de passer vers la
Chine et eux ils seront balayés.
On fait une petite parenthèse sur
l'affaire Scripal.
Affaire Scripal. Bah ça y est, on sait
maintenant. Ce qui est pas étonnant
d'ailleurs, on a vu que le un des deux
gars qui avait parlé à la télévision en
disant j'étais un bon touriste. Les
anglais ont sorti hier qu' lieutenant
colonel au Gru. Bon euh ce qui est sûr
enfin depuis le premier jour l'affaire
scripale si vous voulez c'est c'est oui
c'est une affaire intéressante parce que
indiscutablement alors au départ c'est
vrai qu'on pouvait se poser la question
dis il disant quand même est-ce que
pourquoi les Russes ont fait ça pourquoi
les Russes ont pu faire un truc pareil
et puis c'était oublié en définitive un
principe de base mais vraiment de base
hein euh du service militaire de
renseignement russe qui s'appelle le GRU
dans lequel il a toujours été dit depuis
Berri, c'est dire pas d'aujourd'hui
hein, ça date de l'époque de Lénine et
de Staline. Il a toujours été dit que
quelqu'un qui trahit au profit d'une
puissance étrangère doit être exécuté
quel que soit le temps qui passe et où
que ce soit.
Et ça c'est leur règle. J'en moi
personnellement je pense qu'ils ont même
pas posé la question au-dessus.
Moi je pense qu'ils ont pas demandé à
Poutine parce que c'est la règle chez
eux
et donc ils ont trouvé ça normal. Il
faut pas oublier que quand même monsieur
le Scripal avait quand même dénoncé des
camarades
des copains militaires aux autorités
américaines et anglaises et il les a
fait arrêter et pour certains, ils ont
laissé la peau pas l'oublier.
Donc c'est pas un modèle non plus de
pour pour moi, excusez-moi, c'est bien,
il a trahi pour nous donc c'est
formidable mais sur le fond, ça reste
quand même un traître. On
on fait une petite transition.
Est-ce que Est-ce que vous connaissez la
société Palentir ?
Bien sûr.
Qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que ça vous dit
quand Pasantir travaille maintenant avec
les services de renseignement français ?
Bah ça me dit qu'on est passé ça me dit
ce que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure dire
qu'on est passé à côté de quelque chose
qui était très important. On sait on
sait qu'aujourd'hui, on sait depuis déjà
quelques années hein, certain nombre
d'années, on sait que sur le plan
numérique, il faut il faut absolument
qu'on arrive à à à avoir un système qui
nous permette d'aller chercher dans ce
qu'on appelle les sources ouvertes,
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui est disponible,
qu'on puisse aller chercher très vite
toutes les informations qui peuvent être
intéressantes. Bon, les Américains avec
Palenti, ils ont commencé très tôt et
ils ont eu des financements
considérables par la CIA d'abord par ce
qu'on appelle INCUTEL, un fond
d'investissement de la CIA, ensuite par
la DARPA, c'est l'équivalent de la DGA
chez nous mais avec beaucoup plus de
moyens, ils ont eu des investissements
considérables et évidemment ils sont
arrivés à faire un à faire un outil qui
est actuellement le meilleur dans le
monde occidental. Là-dessus, il y a pas
de problème. Alors, la question c'est
bien entendu, c'est qu'à partir du
moment où ce système a été mis au point
par les Américains
avec l'aide des services de
renseignement et de l'armée américaine,
il est évident que toute information qui
passe par Palentir, il y a une copie aux
États-Unis,
hein. Et si vous en doute, si vous en
doutiez, je vous rappelle quand même
qu'il y a une quand on a ressorti la
RGPD, vous savez cette protection qu'on
a inventé en Europe qui est une belle
invention, mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait les
Américains 2 mois après ? Ils ont sorti
une autre loi qui s'appelle le cloud act
qui autorise l'État américain sans donc
qui oblige tout citoyen américain, toute
entreprise ou toute personne qui est
d'une manière ou d'une autre directement
ou indirectement les États-Américains et
bien à fournir ces toutes les
informations qu'il a et on peut de
l'autre côté aussi allerlu chercher
toutes les informations qu'il détient
pour que les États-Unis puissent
regarder ce qui se passe. si vous
voulez, c'est un système généralisé où
on peut tout savoir. Bon, alors bien
sûr, c'est réserve aux citoyens
américains et à tout ce qui se passe
autour, mais le dollar, l'utilisation du
dollar est une des raisons qui permet
d'aller chercher ce qui se passe. Donc
on est donc on voit bien donc chez chez
eux, c'est normal, c'est bien ça qu'il
faut voir. Chez nous, il y a des règles
parce que c'est des règles de liberté,
de démocratie, de protection de de la
vie privée, il y a plein de choses. Mais
chez eux, le problème n'est pas vu du
tout de la même manière. Alors donc on
sait très bien queir les informations
pour ce qui concerne la DGSI puisque
c'est ça le truc hein. La DGSI a pris
pasir et le directeur général monsieur
Calvard l'a très bien expliqué. Il a dit
"Je prends pas l'entir parce que je n'ai
rien entre les mains au niveau européen
actuellement et pour avoir quelque
chose, il faudra 5 ans. Et moi, pendant
5 ans, je ne peux pas être sans
information pour lutter contre le
terrorisme et pour lutter contre le
reste." Donc la messe était dite, hein,
malheureusement.
Le [raclement de gorge] fait que ce soit
l'ancien l'ancien patron d'Airbus qui se
retrouve à la tête de Palentir.
Vous savez ça déjà ?
Ça change quelque chose ? Non. Comment
il s'appelle ? Brgier non ? Comment il
s'appelle ?
ou
c'est bien que vous sachiez ça ça sorti
cette nuit c'est bien hein Ah ouais le
[grognement] le Ouioui effectivement le
numéro 2 d'Airbus vient de rentrer chez
Palenti comme patron Europe alors ceci
dit c'est pas le premier des grands
chefs d'entreprise français ou des hauts
fonctionnaires à basculer chez les
Américains. Mais alors c'est tout le
problème. Nos Américains sont nos
alliés. Les Américains sont nos amis.
Donc après tout pourquoi pas. Mais comme
disait si bien Churchill, un pays n'a
pas d'amis. Il n'a que des il n'a que
des partenaires
et des opposants.
Vous parlez des États-Unis comme notre
partenaire ou peut-être
Oui. Comme tous les autres.
Est-ce que est-ce que nous français
est-ce qu'on peut encore critiquer les
États-Unis ? Est-ce que notre parole
est libre ?
Non, je crois qu'on peut on peut on peut
que non, les États-Unis, vous pouvez la
paradoxalement, vous pouvez critiquer
les États-Unis à partir du moment où
vous êtes où ils pensent que vous êtes
avec eux.
Si vous voulez le il y a il y a il y a
un dogme intangible, c'est que
l'Amérique c'est l'Amérique hein et en
plus Dieu est avec eux comme chacun sait
hein. Donc ça ça aide hein. Bon donc ça
c'est clair. Mais une fois que vous avez
accepté ça et vous dites "C'est bien
votre truc, il y a quand même des choses
qui vont pas du tout." Là il vous écoute
et je peux vous assurer qu'aujourd'hui
ils écoutent. Maintenant, il faut pas
non plus rêver, hein. Il y a une
différence de puissance et de taille qui
fait que bon, la France est un grand
pays hein, mais on vient de perdre la 5e
la 5e place au niveau mondial par en la
donnant à l'Inde, pays qui fait
aujourd'hui un peu parler depuis
quelques jours hein, pour d'autres
raisons. Euh, [raclement de gorge] ça
veut dire qu'on est en train de perdre
position. On n'est pas on n'est pas on
n'est plus. C'est ça la réalité là,
c'est que la France quoi qu'on fasse et
quoi quels que ce soient les calculs,
les extrapolations pour le futur, la
France dans 2030 ne sera plus dans les
10 premières puissances mondiales. On va
être passé par le Brésil entre autres et
par l'Indonésie par exemple.
On arrive à la fin.
Alors d'habitude vous connaissez notre
dernière question pour les jeunes
générations. C'est laisser un conseil
pour les jeunes générations. Là c'est
plutôt laisser un conseil pour la
France. ouf conseil je serai pas assez
prétentieux pour donner c conseils à la
France.
Non, ce que ce que ce que je pense ce
que je pense c'est que il n'y a pas de
solution désespérée d'abord
et que le pessimisme français
traditionnel est quelque chose de
désastreux parce que quand on se
compare, on n'est peut-être pas très bon
mais quand on se compare aux autres, on
est quand même bien meilleur hein. Donc
donc il faut pas avoir de complexe et je
crois que dans tous les domaines, on a
on a des on a de vraies capacités.
simplement le problème que nous avons
c'est que il faut pour avoir ces
capacités il faut qu'on les encourage.
Donc il faut à côté de la reconnaissance
de ces capacités, il faut aussi avoir
une politique. Là c'est de la politique
dans le sens du bon sens du terme hein,
la la vie de la cité. Et bien il faut
avoir une politique qui fait qu'on va
aider justement la France dans ces
domaines où elle a la possibilité de
faire des différences. Et nous avons,
regardez les mathématiciens, on peut
dire ce qu'on voudra mais en
mathématique aujourd'hui quand vous
allez en Chine ou aux États-Unis, ils
vous parle tous des Français et ils
achètent les Français à prix d'or, hein.
Bon, pour un Vilani, un pour un Cédric
Vilani qui reste en France, mais vous en
avez 10 qui partent et ils partent pas
qu'aux États-Unis, hein. Ils vont
partout parce qu'on leur propose des
choses formidables, des laboratoires
magnifiques et autres. Donc on a il y a
il y a de ce côté-là, oui, c'est il faut
qu'on ait de la formation, il faut qu'on
a qu'on encourage les dans les domaines
qui sont les domaines de où lesquels on
peut on peut s'en sortir. Le troisème,
c'est qu'il faut avoir une politique
cohérente dans la durée
parce que le problème de la France,
c'est que tous les 5 ans, on change de
politique.
Alors c'est bien gentil mais sur le fond
quand vous voyez les Chinois qui Tiaping
qui dit à la fin de Maung il dit voilà
comment on va faire et que 40 ans après
ils ont pas changé ils sont sur la même
ligne. Là vous vous dites il y a une
cohérence il y a une légitimité nous
c'est pas le cas. En définitive, moi ma
conviction plus que des conseils, si
vous voulez essayer de dire, il faut
d'un côté le numérique nous pousse à
l'individualisation, ça c'est clair,
avec toutes les conséquences que ça peut
avoir sur la société. Mais il y a un
deuxième volet, c'est que si on veut
être vraiment fort dans le monde actuel,
il faut qu'on abandonne cette logique de
l'instant qui est la caractéristique des
occidentaux pour aller dans une logique
de vision à moyen et long terme
en en la en la suivant, c'est-à-dire en
la respectant, hein. Trump, il fait de
la surréaction, ça marche et comme ça a
été justement dit, mais dans 10 ans,
dans 20 ans, on verra les résultats.
Pour le moment, ça fonctionne dans 10 ou
20 ans. On verra. Les Chinois quand ils
ont fait, ils ont dit "On va basculer du
marché extérieur, enfin on va basculer
de l'exportation vers le marché
intérieur parce que maintenant on a un
niveau de vie en Chine qui est suffisant
pour faire marcher le marché intérieur
pour faire fonctionner le marché
intérieur. Quand ils ont fait ça et bien
ils ont créé une dynamique entre
parenthèses, elle répondait par avance à
ce que fait Trump aujourd'hui hein.
Quand ensuite ils disent pour repartir
vers l'international, on fait les routes
de la soie, la route maritime et les
deux routes terrestres. Bon, pourquoi on
fait ces routes là ? C'est parce que
méthodiquement, progressivement, en
construisant des ports, en construisant
des antennes, on va peu à peu aller vers
l'Europe. Ils ont déjà désigné leur
cible, hein. Et on va aller vers
l'Afrique.
Donc, en définitive, mais eux, ils ont
le temps pour eux.
Et nous le problème c'est qu'on ne veut
pas se donner le temps. On veut réagir
tout de suite, ça coûte plus cher et
l'expérience montre que c'est moins
efficace.
All juillet. Merci.
Merci à vous. [applaudissements]
Merci à tous. Très bonne soirée. Ah
ouais !
[applaudissements]
[musique]